c'est la présidente qui a du succès mais
je crains que j'aille de désillusion en
désillusion
bon mes chers collègues nous allons
commencer cette audition bien sûr nous
sommes dans le cadre de nos auditions
budgétaires et nous entendons
aujourd'hui Monsieur Marc fenou ministre
de l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire qui vient nous présenter le
projet de budget pour son ministère pour
2023 je vous précise comme d'habitude
que cette audition est diffusée en vidéo
en direct sur le site internet du Sénat
et qu'elle sera disponible ensuite en
vidéo à la demande monsieur le ministre
c'est la première fois que la commission
des affaires économiques vous entend
même si nous avons déjà eu l'habitude de
travailler avec vous en tant que
ministre des Relations avec le Parlement
pendant quatre ans et que depuis votre
nomination nous avons eu quelques sujets
nationaux mais aussi locaux nul doute
que mes collègues profiteront de cette
audition pour faire le tour de
l'actualité agricole elle est
extrêmement riche mise en oeuvre bloquée
des retenues d'eau crise inflationniste
crise énergétique conséquences de la
sécheresse et des incendies influenza à
vierres prédation du loup crise du bio
négociation commerciale à venir j'en
passe sûrement mais le menu est
appétissant je vous demanderai
d'ailleurs mes chers collègues d'essayer
de vous concentrer autant que possible
sur le budget mais nous sommes tellement
contents de vous avoir que voilà
monsieur le ministre vous nous présentez
donc ce soir un budget nominalement en
très forte hausse puisque la mission
agriculture alimentation forêt et
affaires rurale sa croix de 30% passant
de 3 à 3,9 milliards d'euros nous
aurions été ravis de pouvoir nous
féliciter avec vous de cette hausse si
elle ne s'expliquait pas essentiellement
par des mesures de périmètre sur les 880
millions de hausse 430 millions c'est à
dire que la moitié s'explique par la
simple budgétisation enfin simple par la
budgétisation de l'exonération des
cotisations sociales pour l'embauche des
travailleurs Lionel demandeur d'emploi
la fameuse fameuse Théodore auparavant
compensé à la sécurité sociale par
l'affection l'affectation pardon d'une
fraction de la TVA pour le reste le
programme de 106 sur la sécurité
sanitaire de l'alimentation augmente lui
de 7 % portée notamment par la mise en
oeuvre de la police unique de la
sécurité sanitaire des aliments
peut-être vous nous expliquerez vous
d'expliquerez nous nous enfin bref nous
aurons des explications je vais y
arriver en quelques mots sur la nature
de la restructuration que vous mettez en
oeuvre et surtout sur l'efficience
attendue parce que c'est un sujet que
nous avons traité
pas mal de fois ici au Sénat certaines
lignes en revanche peu onéreuses donc
qui passe comme ça un peu
inaperçu au profit de dispositif qui
avait démontré leur efficacité semble
être moins abondé que l'an passé et
Madame la rapporteur Françoise Ferrat en
citera quelques-unes en revanche le
programme 14 19 qui porte notamment sur
les 250 millions de crédits budgétaires
mis sur la table pour la réforme de
l'assurance récolte augmente de 21%. il
faut souligner bien sûr cet effort
budgétaire qui est notable qui découle
de la loi que nous avons voté ici même
si j'allais dire le compte n'y est pas
entièrement et je laisserai bien sûr le
rapporteur le rend Duplomb revenir sur
ce point tout à l'heure dans les
quelques évolutions supplémentaires
n'ont pas voté par les députés mais
retenus par le gouvernement on trouve la
hausse attendue de 10 millions d'euros
en faveur de l'ONF concrétisant
l'engagement du gouvernement a consacré
plus de moyens à la défense des forêts
contre l'incendie mais Catherine mes
collègues bien sûr Anne-Catherine
Loisier et Olivier rickmann ne
manqueront pas de vous interroger à ce
propos nous venons il y a quelques
semaines de valider la nomination de
Madame étrichez et nous attendons dans
les prochains mois un plan de profonde
réorganisation de l'ONF car le seul
ajout budgétaire ne suffit pas
probablement à l'amélioration
souhaitable de l'efficience de l'ONF sur
les territoires vous l'avez compris
monsieur le ministre nous aimerions vous
entendre sur ces éléments structurants
du PLF au-delà de cette mission
budgétaire sur laquelle les trois
rapporteurs donc le rendu plomb
Françoise Ferrat et Jean-Claude Tissot
vous questionneront plus en détail
j'aurais voulu vous entendre sur
l'ensemble des crédits portés par le
ministère mais qui échappe à la mission
agriculture ces montants sont
considérables et donc il nous manquent
par conséquent d'un panorama d'ensemble
je pense en particulier au plan de
relance mais aussi au plan France 2003
qui consacre un million un milliard et
demi d'euros d'un côté de milliards
pratiquement 3 milliards de l'autre
j'aurais voulu savoir si la en fait
comment est-ce que vous pilotez en lien
avec France 2030 c'est ses crédits qu'en
est-il en particulier la mise en oeuvre
du plan entrepreneur du vivant du plan
de résilience Ukraine pouvez-vous nous
faire une synthèse et crédit débloquer
pour faire face aussi aux aléas
climatiques et économiques et nous dire
dans quelle mesure le plan France 200 3
joue son rôle de catalyseur permet-il
vraiment de dessiner l'agriculture de
demain par des investissements par
exemple dans la recherche ou la
robotique enfin si nous avons le temps
nous aimerions que vous nous présentiez
vos intentions et votre agenda pour les
prochains mois et je pense bientôt bien
sûr surtout à la loi d'orientation sur
le renouvellement agricole qui aura elle
aussi des implications budgétaires et
nous aimerions en connaître le périmètre
voilà monsieur le ministre je vous
laisse maintenant nous présenter votre
budget pour 2023 répondre à ses
premières questions après quoi je
donnerai la parole au rapporteur de la
commission pour être parfaitement
transparente le rend Duplomb Françoise
Ferrat et Franck Tissot Jean-Claude
Tussaud je pardon Jean-Claude
Tissot et je laisserai s'il le souhaite
Vincent Segoin et Patrice joli
rapporteur spéciaux de la commission des
finances prendre la parole s'il souhaite
ils ont adopté leur rapport hier puis
naturellement aux collègues qui le
souhaiteront je vous conseille donc
d'utiliser notre cher boucle WhatsApp
pour ce pourquoi elle est faite et non
pas pour des disgressions bizarres du
matin voilà merci beaucoup je vais vous
visser les risques des boucles WhatsApp
de se tromper de dessinateur merci
Monsieur le monsieur le ministre ne vous
écoutons
merci madame la Présidente merci de
votre accueil madame la présidente
monsieur le rapporteur madame la
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs et les
sénateurs je voudrais d'abord vous
remercier de m'avoir convié à venir de
ventre devant votre commission pour
présenter ce budget il me semble que
c'est un rendez-vous particulièrement
utile et notamment dans le contexte que
nous connaissons le contexte budgétaire
mais le contexte agricole vous l'avez un
peu évoqué actuellement l'aspect
stratégique de notre capacité à produire
pour nourrir a été de nouveau mise en
évidence par la guerre en Ukraine et les
crédits de cette mission revêtent par
conséquent une importance particulière
dans le moment que nous traversons pour
crédibiliser notre action mais au-delà
de ces grands bouleversements je
n'oublie pas pour commencer l'urgence
immédiate j'imagine que je serai
interrogé sur la question mais
les questions des coûts de l'énergie la
question des risques cela peut refaire
peser sur la continuité de l'activité
agricole et je suis en contact comme
vous le savez étroit avec le nombre de
filières pour nous citer que l'une
d'entre elles je pense à la filière
endive
pour les soutenir et suivre l'évolution
de leur situation essayez d'adapter les
dispositifs que nous avons déployés ou
que nous allons déployer à la réalité de
ces filières que vous connaissez la
première caractéristique pour en revenir
au budget d'abord de la mission que je
voudrais souligner devant vous c'est
l'augmentation substantielle de ces
crédits qui s'élève cette année à 5
milliards 987 millions d'euros pardon
c'est un milliard de plus par rapport à
l'année prochaine avec le plan de
relance et vous l'avez souligné madame
la Présidente avec France 2030 avec les
financements européens avec les
dispositifs fiscaux et sociaux ce sont
près de 26 milliards d'euros qui sont
alloués ou programmés pour le
développement de l'agriculture et de
l'agroalimentaire c'est dire si c'est
moyen sont importants c'est un budget
qui nous donne les moyens de financer
nos priorités pour bâtir notre
souveraineté alimentaire grâce à
l'engagement sans faille des agents du
ministère des services déconcentrés des
opérateurs qui viendront le traduire
concrètement cette augmentation de
crédit c'est surtout un signal fort à
mon sens pour ce premier budget du
quinquennat c'est un soutien très
concret et décisif avec l'entrée en
vigueur de la réforme de l'assurance
récolte la prolongation du to d e le
maintien des financements dédiés à
l'indemnité compensatoire de handicap
naturel et pour continuer à dynamiser
notre enseignement agricole ou améliorer
notre politique forestière on
permettrait d'ailleurs de commencer par
le soutien à la forêt que je
souhaiterais évoquer en premier lieu
devant vous parce que c'est un aspect
essentiel des crédits de cette mission
que je connais je connais le langage
vend du Sénat et de nombre d'entre vous
sur ce sujet avec les différents travaux
qui ont été réalisés par le Sénat ce
musée est celui d'un soutien appuyé à
notre politique forestière qui s'inscrit
dans la droite ligne des annonces
récentes du président de la République
sur l'objectif de renouvellement de 10%
de la forêt française d'ici 2030 pour
faire face au changement et aux
dérèglement climatique je serai
d'ailleurs prochainement dans un certain
nombre de départements pour traduire de
manière concrète en présentant la
feuille de route gouvernementale vous y
avez fait allusion madame la Présidente
pour la planification forestière et le
volet forestier de France nation vers
autour de quatre axes la prévention des
risques de feu
dans les forêts je réunirai
prochainement les acteurs de la mise en
oeuvre des obligations légales de
débroussaillement qui est l'un des
sujets avant le lancement de travaux
plus larges pour lutter contre
l'émettement de la propriété forestière
le renforcement des moyens de l'ONF pour
la lutte contre les feux naissants et la
DFCI se traduit déjà concrètement dans
ce budget avec d'abord la suspension des
réductions de poste au sein de l'ONF et
10 millions d'euros supplémentaires
prévus dans cette loi de finance auquel
s'ajouteront je lui dis dès à présent
les 10 millions supplémentaires qui ont
été votés par voie d'amendement et
réintégrer à l'intérieur du texte qui
vous a été transmis donc c'est 20
millions de plus qu'aura l'ONF à sa
disposition mais comme vous l'avez dit
on aura peut-être l'occasion d'en
débattre ce n'est pas seulement une
question de moyens vous en avez tout à
fait raison deuxième axe
d'investissement dans les compétences
connaissance avec un grand intérêt du
rapport qui a publié sortie Sénat sur la
compétitivité de la ferme France la
compétitivité est une dimension très
importante pour assurer évidemment notre
souveraineté c'est par exemple pour cela
que nous avons réalisé des
investissements massifs avec France
relance 1,6 milliards d'euros et France
2030 qui sous ses différents aspects et
couvrent près de 2,9 milliards d'euros
mais j'aurai l'occasion à la suite de
cette intervention peut-être de le
détailler si vous le souhaitez madame la
Présidente mélenchez de la souveraineté
alimentaire suppose me semble-t-il de
essayer de maintenir ce qu'on a fait en
montée de gamme mais par ailleurs de
faire face à aux entrées de gamme parce
que c'est sans doute là que nous avons
des choses à corriger c'est le tout le
sens d'ailleurs en tout cas une grande
partie du sens du rapport sénatorial que
vous avez produit c'est le revenu
agricole qui est aussi en est la clé de
voûte et dans cette logique il nous faut
produire plus mais aussi produire mieux
et assumer des transitions écologiques
et sociales pour créer de nouveaux
débouchés j'en viens à la réforme de
l'assurance récolte qui est un élément
structurant non pas seulement du budget
mais aussi deux systèmes assurantiels le
français c'était attendu depuis très
longtemps et grâce au travail qui a été
fait au Sénat et à l'Assemblée nationale
nous sommes parvenus un texte
nous sommes aux côtés des agriculteurs
pour faire face aux effets du changement
climatique et d'ailleurs le PFR présenté
récemment confirme notre soutien en
venant abonder des dispositifs
d'accompagnement sur l'assurance se
récolte dire simplement que c'est le
produit du travail du varen de l'eau qui
avait évoqué trois piliers le premier
c'est un système assurantiel
complètement refondé parce que
objectivement il allait dans le mur
contenu de ce que sont la multiplication
des aléas en volume et en géographie et
deux premiers éléments c'était celui-là
deuxième élément c'était d'accompagner
les transitions agricoles pour faire
face aux dérèglement climatique et ça
c'est ce que nous avons commencé à faire
dans France relance et que nous
souhaitons poursuivre dans France 2030
et puis troisième élément c'était
l'accès à l'eau qui est un élément
déterminant de la stratégie que nous
devons mettre en oeuvre pour faire face
aux dérèglement climatique et ça
suscitera j'imagine quelques questions
afin de financer ce nouveau système
l'effort de l'État fait plus que doublé
il atteint 256 millions d'euros qui
s'ajoutent au 185 millions euros de
crédit européen et au 120 millions
d'euros de taxes affectées avec un
doublement des contributions des
cotisants c'est à dire des agriculteurs
il faut le saluer aussi soit un total de
560 millions en première année avec une
trajectoire que nous voulons atteindre à
600 millions d'euros c'est celle qui
avait été annoncée et la capacité à
pouvoir aller jusqu'à 680 millions
d'euros dans le cas où la réforme
connaîtra un succès plus ample encore
que ce que nous souhaitons ce nouveau
système doit s'accompagner par ailleurs
du nécessaire adaptation des filières je
l'ai dit et donc c'est un des éléments
de la lutte ou de l'accompagnement ou
dérèglement climatique mais ce n'est pas
le seul élément et c'est pas sur cette
seule base que nous devons faire
deuxième élément la Pâque sans citer
l'ensemble des avancées de la page je
voudrais évoquer le soutien au
développement de l'agriculture
biologique avec un objectif de 18%, pour
y parvenir les soutiens dédiés sont été
augmentés 36% par rapport à la
précédente programmation soit 340
millions d'euros la dotation du fond
d'avenir bureau est stabilisée à 5
millions d'euros supplémentaires suite à
l'examen en première lecture je voudrais
également mentionner deux avancées
majeures qui vont avoir leurs
conséquences la conditionnalité sociale
qui vise à respecter mieux des règles
dans le domaine du droit du travail et
le droit à l'erreur qui est un élément
important de la crédibiliseration et de
la confiance qu'on doit réinstaurer
entre l'administration et les
agriculteurs ça suffitra peut-être là
aussi quelques questions troisième
élément la prolongation du Théodose vous
l'avez dit madame la Présidente pour 3
ans elle est déterminante pour les
activités fortement utilisatrices de
main d'oeuvre saisonnière et pour
lesquelles le coût du travail est un
enjeu important ça a été souvent
souligné par des rapports de
compétitivité enfin les moyens je ne
veux pas les oublier de l'outre-mer les
crédits du somme ont été maintenus comme
le budget européen du poséi pour
répondre notamment aux enjeux
d'autonomie alimentaire des territoires
ultramarins qu'il nous reste à
construire nous avons par ailleurs
sensiblement augmenté le budget allé aux
filières sucres de la réunion avec deux
19 millions d'euros supplémentaires
deuxième axe de notre action assurer la
sécurité sanitaire comme vous l'avez
évoqué ces 7% d'augmentation des moyens
par rapport à 2022 trois éléments
principaux un budget complémentaire de
9,4 millions euros à compter de 2023
pour garantir la mise en oeuvre de la
loi santé animale nous allons poser les
jalons d'une sécurité sanitaire
européenne qui constituera à terme un
avantage compétitif pour notre
agriculture nous allons également
fortement renforcer nos contrôles et la
surveillance des dangers sanitaires et
s'ils sont nombreux sans les citer tous
je vois bien ce qui se développe autour
de l'influence de la Vierge de la
bruxellose enfin les crédits de cette
mission permettront la mise en place de
la police unique en charge de la
sécurité sanitaire dont mon ministère
sera désormais responsable c'est une
réponse forte aux préoccupations
légitimes de nos concitoyens parfois à
la suite de scandale sanitaire enfin
dernier axe porté par le ministère celui
de la préparation de l'avenir à travers
ces crédits ceux de la mission
enseignement scolaire que j'aurai
l'occasion de présenter la semaine
prochaine devant la commission de la
culture au Sénat le plafond du casse
d'art est maintenu à 126 millions
d'euros mais j'ai obtenu de bénéficier
de
de l'excédent de recettes 2022 qui
devrait représenter 17 millions d'euros
ce qui est un débat assez récurrent avec
Bercy avec Bercy comme vous le savez et
prenez cette année donc
et ça devrait donc représenter 17
millions d'euros si tu permettra de
renforcer la recherche appliquée et le
développement pour favoriser l'adoption
d'innovation et de changement de
pratique sous en particulier la
transition écologique je l'ai souvent
dit pas d'interdiction sans solution
et de ce point de vue là les moyens de
la recherche des moyens de
l'accompagnement au développement sont
des missions nécessaires pour aller dans
les filières on voit bien qu'on peut se
retrouver face à des impasses techniques
nous investissons également soutenons la
formation grâce aux moyens consacrés à
l'enseignement et à la recherche qui
hors dépenses de personnels s'élèvent en
2023 699 millions d'euros en hausse de
4%, les crédits de cette mission vont
aussi nous permettre la revalorisation
de 4% des bourses pour critères sociaux
de la prime d'internat l'élargissement
de la bourse au mérite l'amélioration
des capacités d'accueil de nos
établissements et de nos écoles
vétérinaires notamment pour les élèves
en situation de handicap nous avions des
retards dans notre périmètre et tout
cela va nous permettre d'amplifier la
dynamique constatée dans l'enseignement
agricole enfin je voudrais conclure sur
un sujet essentiel pour notre
souveraineté alimentaire c'est celui du
renouvellement des générations
le 9 septembre dernier le président de
la République a annoncé les axes de la
future loi d'orientation et d'avenir
agricole l'orientation la transmission à
l'installation la transition et
l'adaptation pour faire face aux
changements climatique et notamment par
l'innovation une large concertation va
s'ouvrir simplement vous donner les
termes de cette concentration c'est une
concertation qui sera menée au niveau
national et au niveau régional dans un
partenariat qui sera celui des Chambres
d'Agriculture des régions et de l'état
parce que me semble que ces trois
acteurs pour des raisons d'ailleurs
différentes les chambres parce qu'elles
sont des opérateurs de la massification
des pratiques qu'on a à mettre en oeuvre
et de très bons observateurs c'est moins
qu'on puisse dire de ce qu'est la
réalité agricole et puis l'État et les
régions parce qu'ils se sont les deux
acteurs de la transition qui peut être
menée au travers leur différents
dispositifs d'intervention avec une
logique et il y aura peut-être des
questions qui est de faire en sorte que
nous réfléchissons ce renouvellement de
génération comme vous le savez c'est
plus de la moitié ou près de la moitié
des agriculteurs qui seront en situation
de pouvoir partir à la retraite dans les
10 ans qui viennent c'est donc près de
200 000 agriculteurs qui vont partir à
la retraite et donc nous avons besoin de
les installer non pas dans quelque chose
qui soit simplement une transmission
reprise une transmission transition pour
s'assurer que nous les installons bien
dans des conditions qui leur permettront
sous le régime de dérèglement climatique
et de dérèglement d'autres natures de
pouvoir s'installer dans des conditions
qui assurent la durabilité des systèmes
sur laquelle on va les installer je sais
d'ailleurs que votre commission des
Affaires économique du Sénat il répondra
une part active avec un objectif que
nous partageons largement celui de
garantir à tous nos agriculteurs un
système viable au service de notre
souveraineté mais sans renouvellement de
génération je le répète il n'y aura pas
de souveraineté agricoles et alimentaire
possible voilà les éléments de préambule
un peu long peut-être madame la
Présidente que je voulais faire sur
cette question budgétaire et ça
suscitera sans doute un certain nombre
de questions
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre vu
du nombre d'inscrits ça suscite déjà des
questions Laurent Duplomb ensuite
Françoise Ferrat et ensuite Jean-Claude
Tissot
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre j'aurais envie de reprendre une
métaphore qui est connue de la plupart
d'entre nous qui dit l'arbre qui cache
la forêt en fait c'est le principe de
regarder à travers un arbre et de ne
plus voir la forêt qui est derrière en
quelque sorte et de façon plus claire
c'est une certaine forme de manque
d'objectivité alors il est vrai que
l'arbre qui cache la forêt c'est les 900
millions d'euros de plus que vous
inscrivez cette année au budget qui
pourrait laisser penser que enfin
nous avons compris la problématique de
l'agriculture française et bien
malheureusement monsieur le ministre
permettez-moi de faire quelques
critiques par rapport à cela mais aussi
à la fin de mon propos de vous faire une
proposition
les quelques critiques c'est que tout
simplement quand on parle d'assurance
récolte
si on veut créer ce que doit faire
l'assurance récolte c'est-à-dire une
forme de confiance avec les agriculteurs
il faut obligatoirement leur donner les
moyens d'avoir confiance les moyens
d'avoir confiance c'était déjà d'avoir
un texte qui soit partagé il a été un
peu au forceps mais il l'a été ce qu'il
faut derrière c'est après avoir pris des
engagements dans l'hémicycle les
traduire dans les actes aujourd'hui
c'est presque le cas on attend encore
les derniers décrets il reste quand même
la commission départementale d'expertise
pour éviter les problèmes que nous
rencontrons et que vous rencontrez
sûrement cette année au niveau des
calamités mais il n'en reste pas moins
vrai que le fait de ne pas inscrire un
montant précis qui correspond à la
réalité de la politique que vous voulez
mettre en place ne crée pas à mon sens
une forme de confiance vous demandez
bien les 120 millions d'euros d'efforts
aux agriculteurs mais vous n'êtes pas
capable d'écrire les 680 millions
d'euros dans le budget qui mériteraient
d'être écrit parce que tout simplement
il correspondrait à la réalité de que
vous avez fini par accepter c'est à dire
les les quatre taux importants c'est à
dire le 20% de franchise les 70% de
subventions les 30 et 50% d'intervention
de l'État ça permettrait d'avoir
vis-à-vis du monde agricole une certaine
forme de respect de ces engagements qui
se traduisent par un écrit ça veut pas
dire que pour autant vous les consommiez
mais vous auriez eu la possibilité de
retranscrire ces crédits à la fin s'il
n'avait pas été consommé donc je pense
que c'est pas obligatoirement la
meilleure façon de prendre les choses le
deuxième élément c'est exactement la
même chose c'est le to d e le président
de la République au salon de
l'agriculture annonce une pérennisation
alors c'est vrai qu'avec le président de
la République comme au discours de
Rungis quand on le relie aujourd'hui il
faut faire attention aux mots parce que
tous les mots ont un sens et que la
difficulté dans la langue française
c'est que parfois le sens entre celui
qui les prononce et celui qui les écoute
pour avoir une différence de consonance
et c'est vrai que dans les discours du
président de la République cette forme
de en même temps qu'on a appris à
connaître se traduit souvent par les
mots c'est vrai que le Président de la
République lors du Salon de
l'Agriculture a dit qu'il voulait
pérenniser le Théodore parce que c'était
un bon système pourquoi ne pas l'avoir
fait monsieur le ministre c'est bien
d'inscrire dans ces 900 millions d'euros
supplémentaires 430 millions qui
proviennent en fait d'une transfert de
budget ou d'un transfert de ligne
budgétaire mais pourquoi ne pas l'avoir
pérennisé en même temps pourquoi avoir
attendu que ça soit un député à
l'Assemblée nationale en plus du groupe
LR qui propose de le reprolonger pendant
trois ans et que ce soit le Sénat pas
plus tard qu'avant-hier qui le périnise
complètement pourquoi ne pas donner un
message clair à nos agriculteurs qui
n'attendent que ça le même sujet c'est
la police alimentaire j'étais favorable
et je l'ai dit plein de fois à votre
prédécesseur je pense qu'il faut qu'on
ait une police alimentaire qui permet de
faire respecter les clauses miroir mais
là aussi c'est pareil quand les
personnes que vous allez récupérer de la
dgccr et les personnes que vous allez
créer pour cette police dans la DGL vous
ne vous les mettez uniquement dans les
départements je ne vois pas comment dans
les départements vous allez traiter le
problème des produits qui arrivent
importer qui ne respectent pas nos
normes c'est un Rungis et sur les
frontières qu'il faut les mettre c'est
pas à venir embêter et encore plus
contrôler la problématique de nos
départements et de ceux qui savent à la
tâche tous les jours alors la réalité
tout ça c'est quoi c'est qu'en fait
aujourd'hui on n'a pas tout compris on
n'a pas compris que derrière la
problématique de ce budget nous avons
une sur administration en France et
beaucoup trop de capacité à
surtransposer cette sur administration
elle est arrivée à faire traduire pour
les agriculteurs une différence c'est
que pendant des années par le progrès
matériel et autres on a pu permettre de
baisser la problématique de du du de la
pénibilité du travail physique mais
aujourd'hui on l'a remplacé par une
pénibilité du travail psychologique et
d'ailleurs à ce sujet je vais vous
donner un exemple monsieur le ministre
parce que ça il faut que vous le garder
il me reste deux petits points le
premier c'est cet exemple vous
connaissez pas monsieur Cyril Testud il
est agriculteur sur la commune du
département juste à côté du mien
l'Ardèche on me condamnera pas d'avoir
pris un exemple de chez moi du lac
d'Issarlès qui parce que alors qu'il
coche la case correspondant à l'unité
qu'on se passe la triste des handicaps
naturels dans sa déclaration pack depuis
15 ans a oublié cette année de la cocher
un oubli une case coût 13950 euros qui
ne vont pas lui être payés
13950 euros c'est ça la
suradeministration française qu'on ne
peut plus accepter alors la proposition
monsieur le ministre je vous en fait une
j'ai reçu la totalité de la restauration
hors domicile ils me disent
qu'aujourd'hui l'inflation galopante des
produits alimentaires qui risquent de
dépasser les 15% à partir du mois
d'avril de l'année prochaine fait
qu'aujourd'hui le coût d'un repas dans
une cantine coûterait 40 centimes de
plus ces mêmes représentants quand je
leur pose la question de tout ce que
nous avons voté depuis quatre ans me
disent qu'entre égalim 1 et Gallim 2
avec climat résilience toutes les
contraintes qu'on a mis à la
restauration hors domicile c'est
l'équivalent de 20 centimes alors je
vous fais une proposition monsieur le
ministre qui nous coûte rien au budget
de la France il faut détendre cette
situation il faut savoir dans une
situation où comme le dit le président
de la République dans une économie de
guerre et bien arrêté de mettre toutes
ces injonctions laisser la possibilité à
la liberté d'entreprendre et limiter
limiter de plus plus nos injonctions
contradictoires qui nous mènent dans le
mur et qui font qu'à un moment ou un
autre nous constaterons les dégâts trop
tard merci Laurent
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues à mon tour de prendre la
parole pour vous parler dans la suite de
deux rapports dont j'étais cours à
porteur de la réforme de la police
sanitaire unique et du soutien aux
agriculteurs en difficulté en
particulier dans le monde de l'élevage
sur le premier point on ne peut que se
réjouir de la mise en place progressive
d'ici au 1er janvier 2024 de la police
sanitaire unique qui était une demande
ancienne de notre commission dans
plusieurs rapports je pense à celui de
Laurent Duplomb sur le sésame à l'oxyde
des thylene ou plus récemment à notre
rapport transpartisan sur l'information
du consommateur avec Fabien gay et
Florence bad tricks compta notre
commission a appelé à clarifier la
répartition des compétences entre
Direction Générale de l'Alimentation et
direction générale de la concurrence et
de la répression des fraudes voilà qui
sera chose faite et votre ministère
obtient pour exercer sa nouvelle mission
la création de 90 ETP ainsi que le
transfert de 60 UTP de la DGCCRF
seulement cette réforme ne puisse pas la
problématique de la sécurité sanitaire
des aliments comme l'ont appelé les
drames heureusement rares et isolés de
cette année buttoni Kinder etc tout
d'abord faisons remarquer que la DGCCRF
disposait de 100 et TP et de plus pour
effectuer les mêmes missions une partie
non négligeable des contrôles sera
délégué par la DGL à des prestataires
privés des prestataires privés ce qui
fait craindre une qualité disparate de
ses contrôles vos services nous disent
que cette délégation permettra aux
équipes de se concentrer sur les
activités à plus forte valeur ajoutée
mais monsieur ministre n'est-ce pas là
un aveu que les contrôles ne sont pas
encore pleinement pris au sérieux dans
notre pays alors qu'un œil est visé
expérimenté permettrait bien souvent de
détecter ce que ne croyez pas détectable
pouvez-vous donc nous rassurer sur le
fait que cette délégation dont on
comprend qu'elle est faite pour des
raisons budgétaires ne signifiera pas la
perte de compétences
par ailleurs nous nous inquiétons que la
pression du contrôle ne soit pas exercée
au bon endroit à cause d'un mauvais
diagnostic à cet instant permettez-moi
de faire appel à vous souvenir de classe
de français et de littérature et un peu
à la manière de la Toinette de Molière
qui grimait en médecin rappelez-vous
voici faire le poumon le poumon vous
dise ce petit nom à voir dans le poumon
d'une cause des tourments d'argan le
fameux malade imaginaire
ce mauvais diagnostic nous continuons de
le poser chez nos producteurs nos
transformateurs nous distributeurs et
nous restaurateurs des coupables alors
que le maillon faible de la protection
des consommateurs c'est le contrôle des
dorés importés le rang vient de
l'évoquer à l'instant en clair nous
voudrions que les effectifs que vous
souhaitez déployer dans les départements
soit un peu plus à Rungis à contrôler
nos importations plutôt que pardonner
moi cette formule quasiment triviale sur
le dos de nos professionnels or en la
matière les compétences restent éclatées
entre les douanes et vos services et il
me semble que cela ne peut que nuire à
l'efficience des contrôles comment
Monsieur le Ministre comptez-vous
renforcer la coordination entre les
douanes et vos services et va-t-on
réussir un jour à muscler pour de bons
avec une police aux frontières digne de
ce nom les contrôles des importations en
coopération avec nos voisins européens
permettez-moi cette instinct monsieur le
ministre de vous poser une question sur
les inquiétudes suscitées par les
coupures d'électricité pour les filières
périssables lors de votre déplacement au
salon de l'alimentation vous avez assuré
que l'agriculture et l'agroalimentaire
seront prioritaires en cas de coupure
d'électricité cet hiver il est impératif
de protéger nos entreprises de ces
secteurs notamment les filières
périssables que ce soit le lait la
viande les fruits et légumes qu'une sur
les frais pas de cette piqûre
d'électricité alors Monsieur ministre
vous avez évoqué les crédits dédiés tout
à l'heure mais sur le terrain est-ce que
des instructions en ce sens ont été
transmises au préfet pour s'assurer
qu'aucune coupure d'électricité ne
vienne porter un coup potentiellement
fatale aux filières de doré périssables
et enfin je ne peux pas conclure sans
dire un mot de la dramatique non non
j'ai raté quelque chose pardon monsieur
le ministre
ah oui tu m'as perturbé madame la
Présidente
ah voilà le sujet tellement à cœur deux
minutes madame la Présidente autre motif
d'inquiétude c'est celui primordial de
la situation des agriculteurs en
détresse une feuille de route a été
publiée en novembre 2021 nourri
notamment par le rapport que nous avons
produit Henri Cabanel et moi et un an
après en raison du caractère transversal
des mesures nous manquons cruellement de
visibilité sur les traductions
budgétaires de cette feuille de route
passer l'an dernier de 30 à 42 millions
d'euros éclatés en diverses actions
cette année on programme et même mission
seulement j'aimerais bien que ce soit
pas un coup de com où en est-on de la
mise en oeuvre de cette feuille de route
et je constate que les crédits de
paiement de l'aide à la relance des
exploitations agricoles qui avaient été
doublées l'an dernier sont en perte de
vitesse 5,2 contre 7,100 millions
d'euros je remarque pourtant avec
satisfaction que la commission des
affaires économiques de l'Assemblée
nationale
à effectuer un focus thématique sur leur
service de remplacement faisant sienne
des recommandations que nous avions
formulées avec Henri Cabanel pour le
rendre plus attractif pour les
exploitants nous sommes favorables à
l'augmentation de la citation via le
crédit d'impôt en complément de cette
intervention fiscale quelles autres
outils voyez-vous pour un augmenter
l'attractivité tant du côté des
agriculteurs que du côté des agents
remplaçants en somme monsieur le
ministre pouvez-vous nous donner une
vision d'ensemble sur cette feuille de
route et nous rassurer sur le fait que
son ambition est maintenue la
mobilisation est-elle bien générale au
sein des services de l'État je pense par
exemple à l'ofb dont les contrôles
stress tellement nos agriculteurs qui
sont arrivés comme cela a été
malheureusement le cas récemment à
commettre le pire ces crucial pour notre
agriculture et en particulier pour notre
élevage qui a beaucoup souffert ces
derniers temps
un petit mot sur justement sur l'aspect
vétérinaire dont nous nous étions
félicité l'an dernier que les stages
tutorés bénéficient d'un financement
satisfaisant on constate cette année une
baisse de près d'un quart des crédits de
paiement pour un dispositif pourtant de
bon sens et peu coûteux permettant de
lutter contre les déserts vétérinaires
comment justifier vous cette baisse
monsieur le ministre enfin je termine
mais je ne peux pas conclure sans dire
un mot de la dramatique crise de
l'influence aviaire qui a coûté plus
d'un milliard d'euros à l'État sur la
saison 2021-2002 répartit en 300
millions d'euros d'aide sanitaire et 800
dettes économiques rapportés à ce
milliard la ligne budgétaire d'un
million d'euros relative à la
vaccination me semble bien peu abonder
je comprends que les verrous
développement de la vaccination ne sont
pas uniquement budgétaires mais
administratif mais n'y aurait-il pas un
moyen de donner un coup de pouce à cet
outil indispensable à la prévention je
vous remercie
merci Françoise je vous presse un peu
parce qu'il y a énormément de questions
Jean-Claude Tissot merci madame la
Présidente je vais
quand même malgré tout faut dire les
choses bien sûr qu'on a le ministre bien
sûr j'ai une minute merci de m'avoir
écouté non
monsieur le ministre madame la
Présidente mes chers collègues je vais
pour ma part être assez succinct mais
monsieur le ministre nous interrogé sur
plusieurs aspects importants de votre
action les forêts confrontés nombreux
défis la recherche indispensable pour
assurer l'évolution de notre modèle et
enfin la question de l'enseignement qui
doit être le principal moteur à mon sens
du renouvellement des pratiques et des
générations dans les années à venir tout
d'abord après une année marquée comme on
sait tous ici par une triste vague des
feux de forêt il est de notre devoir de
ne plus traiter cet enjeu à la légère et
d'avoir une réflexion nouvelle sur ces
espaces et sur cette filière
la question du renouvellement forestier
et donc un sujet majeur à ce stade
avez-vous une estimation du surplus
nécessaire au renouvellement forestier à
la suite des feux de cet été est-ce
qu'un premier bilan des aides consacré
renouvellement forestiers a pu être
réalisé et de manière plus concrète
c'est feu qui ont dévasté des dizaines
de milliers d'hectares en France durant
l'été 2022 doivent nous amener à
repenser les forêts et le mode des
gestion des forêts la question centrales
finalement comment devons-nous replanter
pour avoir des forêts adaptées au
changement climatique plus durable et
moins un risque pour les plans sur le
plan des incendies est-ce qu'une
réflexion est engagée au sein de votre
ministère à ce sujet notamment sur les
questions de mixité au sein des forêts
thématiques particulièrement documentées
il y a de la littérature autant qu'on
qu'on ait le temps de la lire de plus le
président de la République a annoncé
vouloir planter un milliard d'arbres
d'ici 2032 avez-vous une estimation de
cette nouvelle à grande annonce
je poursuis rapidement par les moyens et
les effectifs de l'ONF qui suscitent
logiquement toutes les attentions selon
les trajectoires établies dans le
contrat état ONF 2021 2025 ajusté les
effectifs de l'ONF auraient dû diminuer
de 80 postes en 2023 les récentes
annoncent gouvernementales
confirmés dans votre intervention à
l'Assemblée nationale merci dernier
semble indiquer un renoncement à la
suppression de ses postes aussi Monsieur
le Ministre est-ce que le contrat état
wenf 2021-2025 et maintenu malgré ce
récent revirement de situation si oui ne
serait-il pas plus logique de revoir ce
contrat qui continue de prévoir des
suppressions de poste dans le contexte
actuel traversé par les forêts enfin
nous aurions aimé savoir plus
précisément ce que permettre rond de
financer les 10 millions supplémentaires
accordés à l'ONF en dehors des 3,3
millions fléchés sur la création des 60
postes alors qu'une affectation des
moyens centrés sur l'agence DFCI
d'Aix-en-Provence par la zone sud est
évoquée il apparaît et là mes collègues
vont certainement dire la même chose que
moi il serait souhaitable d'avoir une
plus globale au bénéfice de l'ensemble
des territoires forestiers nous l'avons
vu cet été la prévention des incendies
ne concerne plus seulement le sud de la
France la multiplication des épisodes de
sécheresse et la hausse continue des
températures concernent l'ensemble des
territoires l'ensemble de nos
territoires ces critères doivent être à
mon sens doit être prise en compte pour
assurer une juste répartition de la
réflexion et là je répartition des
moyens ensuite concernant la recherche
agricole j'ai interrogé à de nombreuses
reprises vos différents prédécesseurs
sur la question kasdar qui nous occupent
toutes les années malheureusement les
années se suivent et se ressemblent à ce
sujet alors le on en est discuter
longuement lors des auditions hier le
produit de l'attaque sur le chiffre
d'affaires des exploitations agricoles
affectées au compte d'affectation
spéciale développement agricole et rural
est toujours estimé à 126 millions
d'euros c'est-à-dire exactement au même
montant que l'année dernière malgré le
dépassement systématique de ces recettes
prévisionnels qui a qui a visionne qui
approche les 140 millions et malgré
cette année une inflation qui est
synonyme finalement puisqu'on est à 126
millions qu'on l'année dernière d'une
diminution des moyens en circonstant vos
services nous ont indiqué hier qu'un
compromis avait été trouvé avec Bercy
pour maintenir ce compte d'affectation
spéciale et que les montants qui se
trouveraient au-dessus du plafond serait
mobilisé pour des actions de type casse
d'art monsieur le ministre ces accords
ministériels ne sont pas suffisants face
à la multiplication de ces enjeux
auxquels doivent faire face la recherche
agricole et depuis plusieurs années nous
portons une simple demande
l'augmentation du plafond du casse d'air
au niveau réel des cotisations des
paysans puisque ce sont eux qui mettent
au pot si j'ose dire et nous vous
redemandons très clairement une
transparence totale parce que là c'est
un peu nébuleux je ne mets pas en doute
la bonne volonté de vos services mais
ces débuts de notre part en tant que
parlementaire de comprendre les rôles
comment sont gérés les les reliquats des
dernières années maintenant justement
du casse d'art
alors que les instituts techniques sont
obligés de redoubler d'inventivité pour
trouver des moyens et des techniques
adaptés au changement climatiques ils
ont besoin plus que jamais de pouvoir de
programmer leur recherche sur plusieurs
années vous imaginez bien sans l'épée
sans avoir une sans arrêt une épée de
Damoclès sur l'arrêt d'un financement de
façon plus générale il convient de
s'assurer que les instituts de recherche
et je pense en particulier à l'inrae
puis s'exercer leur mission malgré la
hausse des charges qu'il subisse comme
tout le monde pouvez-vous nous dire si
les évolutions sont prévues pour en
tenir compte et pour tenir compte de
leur situation et leur permettre aussi
un fonctionnement normal de leur
activité s'agissant enfin dans une
agricole madame la Présidente bientôt
terminé nous aimerions que vous reveniez
plus précisément sur des spécificités du
budget relatif à l'enseignement agricole
parmi les moyens supplémentaires
affectés à l'enseigne à cet enseignement
lequel relève de la hausse générale du
budget de l'éducation et lesquels sont
spécifiques à l'agriculture c'est
important pour qu'on sache pour conclure
sur une note un peu plus politique sur
cette thématique je considère que nous
devons réellement nous poser la question
du modèle agricole qui est enseignée
dans les différents établissements face
à la multiplication des difficultés et
des questionnements environnementaux
sécheresse gestion de l'eau utilisation
des intrants etc et face à une
problématique propre au monde agricole
en jeu de la transmission gestion des
exploitations et de l'artificialisation
face au tentations et on en a parlé
longuement les semaines dernière
d'installation énergétique je reviendrai
pas sur sujet là l'enseignement doit
traiter l'ensemble de ces enjeux pour
avoir des agricultrices et des
agriculteurs formés et prêtes à
affronter ces différents défis enfin une
toute dernière question qui est issue
lors des échanges d'hier au soir d'hier
après-midi hier soir tard dans
l'après-midi avec vos directions
générales de la performance économique
environnementale des entreprises il nous
a été indiqué que alors peut-être que
j'ai pas compris mais ça vous permettra
peut-être de dire que j'ai mal compris
donc du coup vous allez nous dire que la
bonne le bon la bonne méthode voilà il
nous était indiqué que les aides
compensatoires à l'explosion des
factures énergétiques pour les
exploitations agricoles sont uniquement
calculées à post et transmise dans un
longtemps pourtant à cause de la très
forte hausse des coûts énergétiques qui
concernent les filières variées de
l'élevage des poulailler porcheries etc
à la production nécessitant du froid le
stockage des pommes entre autres les
endives etc certains exploitants ne vont
pas prendre le risque et moi à la limite
j'ai encourage après certaines personnes
ne pas prendre le risque de démarrer
leur production ou une bande de poulet
enfin vous connaissez le système pour
pas mettre en péril soit l'ensemble
exploitation soit être absolument sûr
aujourd'hui avec les éléments donc qui
ont qu'ils ont leur possession d'être
infaillite dans 6 mois c'est absolument
obligatoire puisque le coup le produit
ne couvrira pas le coût de production
ainsi Monsieur le Ministre est-ce qu'une
réflexion est engagée et je vous dis
solennellement parce que là c'est
vraiment du de la vraie vie vous
permettre est-ce que oui est-ce qu'une
réflexion est engagée pour permettre un
mécanisme par anticipation du coup ne
pas attendre N+1 qui soulagerait
directement les agriculteurs voilà j'ai
été un petit peu long mais merci madame
la Présidente de m'avoir laissé
le temps en général quand on promet
d'être court c'est mauvais signe donc
trois sénateurs trois styles mais
beaucoup de questions et je vais vous et
je vais vous laisser répondre déjà au
rapporteur et ensuite je passerai la
parole à l'ensemble des autres
intervenants
je vais essayer d'y répondre en essayant
d'être long ce qui me permettra
peut-être d'être court
la réglementation donc autant se le dire
j'ai bien noté votre question j'y viens
oui j'ai ce que c'est bien ce que nous
avons et puis par ailleurs il y a il y a
des choses dont on savait qu'elle
nécessite un dialogue entre les filières
alors tout va bien jusqu'à ce que on
fasse rencontrer les filières ou parfois
les avis ne sont pas de même nature même
si tout le monde rentre avec les mêmes
intentions et arrivant en cours de cet
épisode j'ai pu découvrir à quel point
ça pouvait être intéressant à regarder
et moi j'ai fait en sorte en plus de ne
pas nourrir les querelles entre les
filières ce que je pense qu'on a intérêt
à ce que le système fonctionne pour tout
le monde et je crois que partageons ce
point de vue deuxième élément vous dites
tant que vous y êtes si vous voulez
crédibiliser ces crédibilisé par la loi
c'est crédibilisé par désormais les
règles qui sont posées il faudra être
crédibiliser par le budget oui mais il
faut aussi crédibiliser le budget c'est
à dire ne pas faire croire on sait très
bien tout ça a été vu d'ailleurs avec
les organisations syndicales agricoles
avec les filières on a une trajectoire
on a une trajectoire triennale qui nous
amène dans le trienna la 600 millions
d'euros donc il y a c'est posé sur la
table il me semble que budgétairement
c'est plutôt de bonne oeuvre de dire on
sait que cette année on est dans le
autour de 560 millions d'euros et qui ça
nous amène dans le trial si les calculs
sont bons si les trajectoires sont
bonnes mais après la réaction des
agriculteurs on ne la connaît ni ou ni
moi et donc on est bien dans 600
deuxième élément pour être très précis
pour le coup parce que vous avez dit les
mots du président ont un sens et vous
avez raison de le dire il a dit
textuellement à terre de gym c'est 600
qu'on mettra dans le triennal et deux si
ça débordait jusqu'à 680 millions
d'euros l'état couvrira par ses moyens
propres
l'assurance récolte donc il ne pouvait
pas être question de ce point de vue là
de toute façon d'aller à 680 millions
d'euros puisque c'est bien la couverture
de quelque chose qui serait plus
puissant il me semble qu'on a un travail
à faire collectivement notamment
me semble-t-il et je dirais un mot par
ailleurs de calamité agricole puisque
vous avez juste et ferez le sujet il me
semble que nous avons un travail à faire
maintenant c'est de conviction auprès
des agriculteurs
il y a un certain nombre de secteurs on
le sait vous le savez beaucoup mieux que
moi qui de l'arboriculture au prairies
ont besoin d'être convaincus de la
solidité du système donc ça c'est nous
tous et puis c'est évidemment les
organisations professionnelles agricoles
qui doivent pouvoir le porter sur le
terrain parce que je pense que c'est un
dispositif qui est solide deuxième
élément j'ai répondu sur la question des
calamités ça me permet de dire au
passage que comme vous le savez nous
avons accéléré ce qui n'avait jamais été
fait le processus de reconnaissance et
donc de versement des calamités
agricoles je le sais sur 12 départements
et pas l'ensemble des départements n'ont
pas été traités mais si on traite tous
les départements on aura le même
embouteillage je rappelle que calamité
agricole c'était plutôt versée en mars
avril les premières versements
interviendront début décembre pour les
12 départements concernés en partie ou
en totalité ça n'empêche pas que nous
continuons à faire le travail de terrain
pour faire en sorte qu'on regarde les
autres départements qui pourraient
rentrer dans la vie il y a en revanche
un sujet qui est un sujet effectivement
de débat c'est par quel voisin nous
c'est ça c'est sur le système prairial
c'est bien ça la question si j'ai bien
compris sous-jacente on reconnaît
la dégradation telle qui est plus
justifier de faire recours au système
assurantiel du jour ou de demain si je
peux dire aussi système des calamités
agricoles moi je le dis très simplement
le système
di Airbus enfin le système satellitaire
c'est il fonctionne dans 90 à 95% des
cas donc je nous invite collectivement à
être prudent ne faut pas jeter le bébé
avec l'eau d'humain si vous me permettez
cette expression ça peut pas être si on
veut décide de faire des enquêtes
terrain sur toutes les prairies de
France les gens seront payés deux ans
plus tard donc on ne sait pas faire ça
et on ne peut pas faire ça en revanche
ce que j'ai dit c'est qu'on a d'ailleurs
on y va on va y travailler avec les
secteurs concernés parce que c'est
vraiment le secteur primal pour regarder
quand on a un désaccord entre le
satellite
et le terrain de regarder qu'est-ce
qu'on peut avoir comme ferme de
référence qui permettront de
crédibiliser définitivement mais j'ai
entendu certains qui décrédibilisaient
pas vous du tout
crédibiliser le système satellitaire le
système satellitaire il marche
il peut y avoir des pour des raisons
diverses et variées des choses qui ne
sont pas vues mais il me semble que
c'est un élément je disais ça quand
j'étais à Cournon c'est pas parce que la
météo se trompe de temps en temps qui
n'est pas utile de la regarder tous les
jours
ça marche globalement et il peut y avoir
des défauts et des failles dans le
système j'ai essayé de pas être aussi
long sur chaque point parce que madame
la Présidente je vais finir par être
non on essaie de s'auto réguler madame
la Présidente j'essaie de faire comme
tout le monde c'est dire si vous avez de
l'autorité sans être autoritaire non
mais c'est vrai de deuxième chose ça
vient du coeur c'était vraiment pas
préparé deuxième chose que je voulais
dire sur le théoday alors ça me
permettra de répondre il y a eu
enfin
qui m'avez interrogé sur le Théo de
l'engagement du président des pays
c'était pour de faire en sorte que tous
les ans comme on a eu d'ailleurs il y a
des Marronniers comme on dit budgétaire
c'était le marronnier de est-ce qu'on
maintient les budgets des chambres
d'agriculture le marronnier c'est le cas
de le dire sur les affaires de bois et
de défibois et le tenait odeur c'était
tous les ans une mise en sursis des
choses le président le dit dans le
budget que nous proposons d'abord on le
réintègre donc c'est une élément de
crédibilisation quand même dans le
budget du ministère de l'Agriculture
deuxième élément on a une perspective
qui a trois vous aurez des débats au
Sénat plus on donne de la prévisibilité
mieux c'est mais il me semble qu'il y a
trois ans déjà sur un dispositif comme
celui-là c'est intéressant il me semble
d'ailleurs moi je le dis personne à
titre de réflexion comme ça que je livre
il me semble que il faut qu'on regarde
ce qu'il peut y avoir comme nécessité je
pense en particulier à ce que vous dites
sur la compétitivité des filières pour
regarder dans quelle mesure il y aurait
des ajustements nécessaires pour aller
sur les filières qui pour le coup là
pour le pour lequel la main d'oeuvre est
un sujet absolument déterminant de comp
activités donc on prolonge le Théod tel
qu'il est on le prolonge pour 3 ans il
me semble que c'est plutôt une avancée
même si elle vous paraît insatisfaisante
et je pense que ça va plutôt dans le
dans le bon sens police sanitaire ça me
permettra pour le coup c'est là qu'il y
avait deux
itérations de répondre aussi
à la sénatrice fera il me semble qu'il y
a plusieurs choses qu'il faut dire
d'abord on a des moyens complémentaires
90 et TP en plus des moyens qui sont
transférés de la DGCCRF
deuxième élément il faut se le dire il y
a quand même à faire converger des
cultures qui n'étaient pas tout à fait
des mêmes maisons
on va mettre en place les choses de
regarder et d'avoir une vigilance
particulière sur les endroits on a des
besoins plus spécifiques contenus de ce
que sont les risques
et contenu de ce que sont les besoins
alors c'est vous dites départementales
il me semble 20 sans jouer sur les mots
Rungis s'est dépassé c'est dans les
effectifs du département du 94 mais je
crois pouvoir vous dire que les
effectifs du 94 sont plus importants que
les effectifs du Loir-et-Cher donc c'est
pas tant la question de me sentir
départementale ou pas national ou
départemental c'est bien que les gens
soient Rungis donc ils sont physiquement
localisés si vous permettez après qu'on
regarde finement et cette merveille
qu'on va faire dans les dans les
semaines et les mois qui viennent
comment aurait les réparti par rapport
aux besoins parce que vous avez raison
dans vos deux expressions je partage
votre sentiment le sujet c'est bien
celui-là c'est l'éclauses miroir c'est
les fraudes c'est les risques sanitaires
qui sont afférents de produits qui
viennent de chez nous et puis ce de
crédibiliser nous-mêmes quand nous avons
des actions d'export vis-à-vis de nos
partenaires à l'extérieur de nos
frontières voilà ce que je voulais dire
sur ce premier élément deuxième élément
pour compléter
on est en train de travailler sur la
manière dont se serait déléguer les
contrôles alors il faut dire aussi
d'abord il faut dire une chose
je souffre pour sans doute comme
beaucoup d'entre vous du fait que il y a
des scandales sanitaires et par nature
c'est des scandales et par nature c'est
scandaleux encore plus qu'un des vies
humaines qui sont mises en cause mais
nous sommes le pays si ce n'est le plus
avancé ou le plus le meilleur en termes
de sécurité sanitaire des aliments enfin
l'accrédit-on pas collectivement l'idée
que nous en rabattrions et c'est pour ça
que c'est plutôt le sujet que vous
évoquez
c'est exactement ce que je disais le
sénateur people donc la question la
police sanitaire c'est de maintenir ce
niveau d'exigence mais ce niveau
d'exigence c'est l'un ou le meilleur du
monde j'en parlais avec eux
des gens qui travaillent sur ces sujets
là aux États-Unis n'est pas du tout et
je fais pas de grief on n'est pas du
tout dans le même registre en termes de
scandale sanitaire alors le risque zéro
c'est ce vers quoi il faut tendre mais
la question que vous posez plutôt celle
là je partage votre sentiment et donc
dans le travail que nous allons faire
puisque c'est une montée en charge
progressive je rappelle que la décision
était durée de prise en avril
semble-t-il de la convergence il faut
qu'on il faut qu'on y travaille il me
semble-t-il et deuxième élément donc on
travaille sur qu'est-ce qui pourrait
délégué on travaille notamment sur de le
délégat des organismes qui ont déjà des
vocations sanitaires par exemple des
organismes de contrôle de végétaux
qui ont déjà une expertise et qui ont
une expertise reconnue d'intérêt général
si je peux dire et donc ça c'est un
élément qui me paraît me paraît
important à dire voilà sur la question
de la police
sanitaire sur la sur la sur
administration et proposition parce que
c'est une proposition de
désuranistration si vous permettez les
choses
alors les cas que vous évoquez il est
d'ailleurs déjà dans nos alors c'est le
cas particulier pour éclairer une
multiplication des cas particuliers peut
faire parfois système reconnaissons le
donc
j'étais assez pour tout vous dire
arrivant à ce poste et Farid du fait que
l'oubli de cochage d'une case puisse
avoir des conséquences il y a pas de
mauvaise intentions je le dis parce
qu'il faut défendre aussi les
administrations de la part des
administrations le système tel qu'il a
été conçu dans la pacte qui se termine
il ne permet pas le droit à l'erreur et
donc il produit ça
parce qu'après c'est des mécanismes qui
sont des mécanismes de contrôle je le
regrette absolument comme vous c'est
pour ça que j'ai moi-même présidé la
réunion qui s'est tenue et qui se tient
pour la mise parce que la PAC a été
décidé je pense qu'elle est plutôt de
bonne facture la mise en œuvre de la
pacte pour faire pour éviter les écueils
qu'on a connu dans la précédente
programmation au début et incapacité à
payer dans les délais c'est un élément
très important et j'attache une
importance particulière ça va de ce
point de vue là dans votre sens à la
question de d'un réel doit à l'erreur et
donc en particulier sur les sujets que
vous évoquez précisément la question de
dire
on note un problème dans votre
déclaration on vous le signal vous
pouvez corriger vous pouvez modifier
dans une durée qui est beaucoup plus
longue
ça ça me paraît de nature à répondre non
pas à la situation précise mais en tout
cas essayer de résoudre alors on regarde
les situations précises croyez bien
qu'on essaie de le faire dans les
services mais ça permet de répondre à la
question que vous sollicitez c'est qu'il
y a un peu de bienveillance parce que
c'est ça le droit à l'erreur c'est qu'on
peut se tromper de cocher une case on
peut oublier ça nous est d'ailleurs tous
arrivé sans conséquence de paiement de
la Pâque mais ça nous est tous arrivé
dans une déclaration d'impôts de pouvoir
le doigt de recommencer sa déclaration
donc ça c'est un élément j'en reviens à
votre proposition alors pardon de vous
le dire sans être trop long mais il y a
des registres de nature différentes
c'est vrai que parfois le la
surperposition des choses sont des
superpositions qui peuvent créer de la
dépense ou ça souvent été documenté
moi-même et restant conseiller municipal
et conseiller communautaire j'ai souvent
c'est pas très nouveau pour tout vous
dire j'ai peur que ça fasse au moins 27
ans que je le dise que la superposition
des choses crée parfois des surcos c'est
pas tout à fait le même nature égale
Lille c'est une intention personne n'est
pénalisée parce qu'il n'atteint pas
égalime non non
personne n'est vraiment pénalisé et
c'est pour l'instant c'est pas
bon alors après vous dites d'autres
sujets c'est les coûts inflationnistes
là et de la loi AGEC moi il me semble
qu'après une fois qu'on le faut qu'on
assume le sujet c'est plutôt qu'on se
pose la question pardon je dis aussi
franchement que ça quand on vote des
textes de regarder les conséquences
qu'on peut avoir et parfois c'est tout
le monde est paraît des meilleures
intentions tout le monde est d'accord
pour sortir des emballages plastiques et
puis après la traduction c'est pas la
même j'essaie de ne pas opposer quand
même des nécessités quand même qu'on a
pour orienter des choses
personne n'a envie qu'on continue à
avoir une une logique d'emballage
plastique telle qu'elle est sur le donc
il faut bien un moment qu'on vote des
dispositions législatives après la
question et c'est peut-être une des voix
qu'il faut avoir c'est le moment de la
transition c'est à dire que je pense que
la durée de transition est un sujet
qu'il faut avoir avant nous c'est tout
le sujet pour moi en agriculture de la
planification de leur conseil la
trajectoire si ça doit être un an c'est
un an si ça doit être cinq ans c'est 5
ans et si ça doit être dix ans c'est 10
ans ça crédibilise la démarche et ça
permet aux opérateurs aux acteurs aux
acteurs collectivités locales me
semble-t-il de pouvoir s'adapter
j'en viens à Madame Ferrat j'ai répondu
sur la sur la question sur la question
de la
de des contrôles sécurité sanitaires sur
les questions du
des moyens dédiés aux mal-être agricoles
c'est un sujet dont nous sommes saisis
grâce à la sollicitation de beaucoup
d'entre vous au Sénat et à l'Assemblée
nationale
d'abord je le dis mais c'est pas ici que
je devrais le dire mais je le dis quand
même puisque c'est une partie du
mal-être agricole il est la situation
financière
il est le sentiment d'être dans une
impasse il est le regard que disent les
choses que disent des gens
à longueur de journaux et de médias
et donc nous avons collectivement en
tout cas moi j'essaie de prendre ma part
j'ai pas c'est pas une injonction contre
vous mais collectivement il faut qu'on
soit extrêmement vigilant quand vous
avez des gens qui passent leur temps à
dire aux gens vous agriculteurs qui sont
pollueurs qui sont dans une impasse que
il faut que tel filière disparaisse que
par nature on ferait ça c'est quand même
quelque chose qui construit le mal-être
psychologique des agriculteurs et donc
il faut qu'on lutte absolument
collectivement contre ça et vous m'avez
trouvé et vous me trouverez assez ferme
sur les prix parce que je pense que
c'est le minimum qu'on doit vous
agriculteurs quand on a parfois des
difficultés à résoudre les deux items je
réponds précisément à votre question
c'est près de 12 millions d'euros par an
un budget supplémentaire sur les
dispositifs d'intervention plus de 12
millions de plus
alors je vais vous les donner mais on
voulait donnera dans des tableaux que je
n'ai pas sous les yeux mais
je vais essayer de vous le dire en tout
cas à l'oral mais on voulait on voulait
je propose que mes équipes voulaient
fassent passer plus 3,5 millions pour le
dispositif area plus 1,4 pour le
dispositif aide au répit qui est de
l'accompagnement que fait la MSA plus
2,3 millions pour les aides financières
de la MSA à destination des entreprises
pour l'amélioration des conditions de
travail parfois c'est un sujet pour des
agriculteurs plus 1,6 millions pour le
débranchement durant du crédit pour
remplacement
et plus j'y retour alors je pense que
nous devons faire encore plus la
promotion des
de la du service de remplacement ça
n'est pas dans la culture du monde
agricole que de se dire j'ai besoin de
répit
et donc il faut qu'on essaie de
porter pour une charge qu'on leur fait
porter inconscient enfin je sais pas je
sais pas comment vous exprimer ça
autrement et de leur dire que on a le
droit au répit on a le droit aux
vacances on a le droit d'avoir envie de
prendre deux jours c'est pas c'est pas
une faiblesse et donc c'est il faut
aussi qu'on a sur la promotion et puis
3,1 millions d'euros de prestations
remise d'un dus pour précarité etc de
prestations de la MSA ça c'est les
éléments budgétaires pour le déploiement
du plan de prévention
il y a une cinquantaine de départements
dans lequel il est correctement pour
être juste avec vous 50 départements
dans lequel il est correctement déployé
j'ai demandé j'ai fait j'ai tenu une
réunion une quinzaine de jours pour dire
que maintenant il fallait que ça finisse
de se déployer dans l'ensemble des
départements
c'est une question moyen mais c'est une
question aussi de de mise en réseau
d'acteurs les champs de l'agriculture la
MSA parfois les collectivités locales
qui peuvent avoir un regard et pour
avoir le je pense en particulier au
département et donc c'est aussi ça sur
lequel il faut que nous puissions jouer
pardon sur ces affaires-là donc on va
assouplir
on avait des engagements dans la feuille
de route l'assouplissement de la
procédure d'aide à la relance des
exploitations agricoles la réa donc un
octroi ou du RSA en urgence aux
agriculteurs j'avais un débat l'autre
jour en me disant les agriculteurs ne
demandent pas le RSA mais je sais bien
qu'il ne demande pas le RSA mais dans
une urgence qui est l'urgence de vivre
le médecin c'est pas une
c'est pas pour faire du RSA c'est juste
que dans des situations d'extrême
précarité c'est une voix et un moyen là
aussi qu'il faut qu'il faut assumer
comme tel pour permettre à une chute
soudaine des revenus et puis il y a
évidemment les éléments alors ça c'est
pas ceux qui sont actifs mais c'est les
éléments des lois dit Chassaigne 1 et 2
d'ailleurs il s'appelle Chassaigne 1 et
2 sur la revalorisation des retraites
agricoles il y a des progrès qui peuvent
être faits un élargir enfin s'assurer
que le dispositif est bien couvert dans
l'ensemble des départements et puis de
faire vivre en permanence et moi à
chaque fois que je me déplace je demande
au préfet comment ça se passe dans quel
situation on est quels sont les
difficultés que vous rencontrez voilà ce
que je voulais vous dire sur les moyens
sur la philosophie il faut que nous
ayons pour essayer d'avancer sur cette
sur cette question alors j'ai perdu ma
feuille donc je n'ai pas la suite si
vous m'avez vous m'avez évoqué pardon
j'ai oublié je voulais pas ne pas
aborder cette question du sujet qui a eu
des contrôles et en particulier d'un
contrôle
dans lequel à l'issue à la à l'issue ou
dans la foulée de ce contrôle on assiste
on a eu malheureusement le suicide d'un
agriculteur j'ai demandé j'ai dit
déjanté j'ai demandé à ce qu'on dit des
gens une enquête administrative pour
savoir dans quelle mesure et dans quel
de quelle manière s'était passé le
contrôle alors j'essaie de vous dire les
choses avec la pondération que beaucoup
me connaissent ici il faut qu'on assume
il faut qu'on assume la nécessité de
contrôle
on a besoin de faire des contrôles il
faut qu'on assume aussi attends je
il faut qu'on a je peux pas ne pas je
peux pas ne pas le dire parce que c'est
au fond ce que je pense il faut qu'on
assume aussi le fait qu'il faut qu'on
arrive à trouver des voies et moyens
pour que la confiance
se renforce sur la question des
contrôles il y a plusieurs choses un la
multiplication des contrôles ça rejoint
un peu ce que vous dites c'est à dire
que parfois vous avez un contrôle sursis
un contrôle sur ça et donc il faut quand
même qu'on essaie de regarder deux qu'on
essaie d'avoir des contrôles qui soient
des contrôles qui ne portent pas d'abord
la charge
et qui sait de démontrer que la parole
de contradictoire puisse être entendu
mais vous m'entendrez pas comme ministre
de la même communiste de l'agriculture
ce serait une facilité dire il faut il
faut rabattre et mettre en cause des
agents il a la plupart des agents de
l'OV ils font leur travail comme la
plupart des gens qui font des contrôles
c'est jamais très amusant de faire un
contrôle mais après la question
d'essayer de retrouver de la confiance
dans ses affaires là peut-être que
quelqu'un parlera de ça mais tout à
l'heure mais ça n'a rien à voir avec le
budget mais les questions de prédation
c'est une question de confiance par
exemple sur le dénombrement
et donc on a besoin de retrouver la
confiance de la confiance des agents et
de la confiance des agriculteurs
vis-à-vis du contrôleur et là il y a un
travail qui est à faire me semble-t-il
sur le cas particulier c'est un cas
douloureux d'abord par nature et je
pense à sa famille et est-ce qu'il a
vécu les
sujets de
comment dirais-je qui amène au suicide
cette suffisamment complexe pour pas
m'aventurer sur les choses ça n'empêche
que ça pose des questions sur la manière
dont ils peuvent se dérouler les
contrôles et le sentiment qui peut être
vécu peu importe qu'il soit à tort ou à
raison
oui mais je dis attention mais vous
m'entendez pas dans mon propos daigné
le sujet je dis il faut qu'on y
travaille c'est à dire que la question
c'est d'arriver à faire dialoguer tout
le monde pour dire voilà les conditions
dans lesquelles doivent se passer les
choses voilà comment on évite les
superpositions de contrôle et voilà
comment on met pas les gens les acculent
pas avec le sentiment d'une espèce de
culpabilité
il y a beaucoup de cas où c'est parce
que alors je le dis d'ailleurs au
passage parce que on ne connaît pas bien
la réglementation alors l'une des sens
ignorer la loi mais reconnaissons
sinon c'est Monsieur c'est Monsieur
Duplomb qui va le dire après en remontre
reconnaissant que la loi est complexe
j'ai demandé d'ailleurs dans le travail
que j'ai j'ai effectué avec le directeur
de l'OSB est vraiment je crois qu'il
veut s'engager avec ses agents là-dessus
c'est la modification de la PAC il y a
de nouvelles règles
et donc il faut qu'on ait une période au
moment on va mettre en oeuvre la plaque
on regarde ça avec qui est la capacité
de
d'appréhender et de
sa culture et si vous permettez cette
question aux nouveaux dispositif de la
PAC il y a des écorigine il y a des
choses nouvelles il y a la question du
calcul des enfin bref je vais pas faire
le détail de la pacte devant vous mais
là on a besoin quand même qu'on se donne
des règles pour que le 2 janvier on
commence par voilà ça n'empêche pas
qu'il faut des contrôles c'est une
question d'ailleurs de crédibilité sinon
de crédibilité dans les dispositifs
d'aide tout le monde fait des contrôles
sur les aides il me semble que c'est un
élément important pardon je voulais le
dire parce que c'est comme vous l'aviez
évoqué c'était un sujet qui dernier
alors dernier point alors sur les
crédits vétérinaires la dotation des
stages n'a pas diminué mais le nombre
d'étudiants
a augmenté en fait donc c'est plutôt
comme ça que l'explication se fait
oui mais comment
oui ça fera partie de notre débat
budgétaire je réponds à votre
imagine qu'en séance par ailleurs on a
un sujet plus lourd et compris de
mal-être aussi chez les vétérinaires
troisièmement on a un sujet on rencontre
dans le monde vétérinaire ce qu'on
rencontre dans le monde médical
on a un besoin je suis en train de
travailler avec les professionnels de
savoir de nouveaux mécanismes qui se
montent en terme vétérinaire de clinique
de grande ampleur qui viennent
privilégier plutôt
la médecine
vétérinaire canine comme on dit
oui donc oui mais ça c'est pas la
question c'est pas la seulement la
question du tutorat c'est la question
des mécanismes il y a il y a un décret
qui est en attente qui peut régler un
certain nombre de problèmes et de
questions sur ce sujet-là donc c'est la
panoplie des sujets mais nous en
reparlerons évidemment sur le sur le
sujet sur le sujet budgétaire
crise influence ça vire je ne sais plus
quel était la question
comment
oui alors le vaccin alors
on va je disais ça et c'est vraiment pas
pour plaisanter les éleveurs sont en
train de vivre ce qu'on a pu vivre dans
une autre crise sanitaire qui était la
crise pour ce qui était des
restaurateurs ou d'autres c'est
confinement des confinements confinement
des confinements bon je vois très bien
la situation de détresse dans laquelle
ils sont simplement aujourd'hui moi
j'essaie de prendre mes décisions sous
le sous le regard des scientifiques en
particulier de ce que dit lances de ce
que dit la DGL et il nous disent
aujourd'hui que je vais venir sur le
vaccin que les dispositions qu'on a sont
de nature à essayer de freiner cette
influence là qui est très particulière
en plus cette année puisque elle est
restée sur le territoire national en
faune sauvage et qu'elle repart en
partie de la faute sauvage du territoire
national et elle vient être renforcée en
ce moment pas le phénomène migratoire
et donc c'est les migrations de faune
sauvage sont en train de venir on est à
49 cas aujourd'hui on a des points de
très grande vigilance
parce que ça aussi c'était une atypicité
2021-2022 sur en région paysoire et
Bretagne parce qu'en plus c'est la
région des accouvoirs c'est la région où
on produit et donc ce qui se passe on
peut les lois et Bretagne c'est ce qui
va se passer dans le Sud-Ouest c'est ce
qui s'est d'ailleurs passé
et donc on va on va être obligé de
graduer les mesures je lui dis ce matin
sur Public Sénat d'ailleurs je crois en
disant on est en train de regarder
comment évolue l'influenza pour regarder
il faut pas avoir des mesures d'un
niveau supérieur personne ne prend
plaisir à ça deuxième élément le vaccin
on est on va assez vite quand même
puisque autorisation au mois de juin
lors d'un Conseil européen le
immédiatement le process
d'expérimentation s'est lancé
trois ou quatre pays dont la France qui
lance l'expérimentation les premiers
éléments mais prenons-le avec la
prudence les premiers éléments sont
plutôt encourageants le résultat on aura
les résultats en décembre décembre
janvier ce qui nous permettra on
l'espère d'avoir un plan de vaccination
parce qu'il faut avoir une stratégie
vaccinale quels sont les volailles quels
sont le type de d'animaux qu'on
vaccinant priorité et deuxième élément
sur lequel il faut qu'on travaille c'est
les éléments qui ne viennent pas non
plus freiner l'export à l'extérieur des
frontières Union européenne parce qu'une
partie de notre filière volaille elle
exporte
donc c'est
qualification du vaccin c'est ça c'est
mon expert pour descendre c'est ce qu'on
nous dit deuxième élément
c'est la capacité en même temps de
négocier et de regarder au niveau
européen comment avec les pays tiers on
se met bien d'accord sur les modalités
d'export peut-être que ça peut faire
évoluer notre stratégie vaccinale et
puis stratégie vaccinale on va déployer
j'ai espoir alors je vais jamais donner
trop d'espoir qu'on a passé mais j'ai
espoir quand même que
passer cet épisode d'influence de la
Vierge on puisse avoir au travers du
vaccin un certain nombre de solutions
mais nous sommes dans la crise donc
c'est je peux pas dire que j'ai résolu
là le sujet l'influence avia mais
j'aurais vraiment saluer le travail qui
est fait en plus je le dis franchement
avec les organisations professionnelles
de ces sujets là sur ces filières là qui
sont faits dans les départements parce
que
dans beaucoup de départements les ddspp
les DDT sont mobilisés y compris parfois
le jour et nuit compris pendant les
périodes de fête parce que il y a un cas
qu'il faut faire les zones de protection
parce qu'il faut faire les caressages
parce qu'il faut s'organiser franchement
la continuité la solidarité qui s'est
d'exercer entre les collectivités qui
sont pas parfois revenus en soutien les
services de l'État en territoire qui ont
été H24 parfois et les filières est
assez remarquable donc mais je vois très
bien le sentiment que il y a une forme
de désespérance et pour certains
éleveurs de dire en sortira jamais d'où
les mesures d'accompagnement mais je
reviens pas vous les connaissez donc je
reviens pas là-dessus j'en finis sur la
question les deux questions
comment ah oui oui mais je oui
je suis vraiment trop long mais enfin
c'est quand même des sujets
coupures d'électricité oui c'est alors
on a faut dire une chose oui
l'agroalimentaire la continuité la
chaîne alimentaire on peut pas se faire
de grief entre nous là-dessus c'est
exactement ce qu'on a fait sur la covid
est-ce que c'est simple non parce que
quand vous êtes dans des coupures
électriques dans des zones où vous avez
une entreprise en bout de la ligne et
que vous avez un circuit pas simple donc
ça ça nécessite un travail fin on va on
réunit depuis plusieurs semaines
chaque semaine sous l'autorité de
Matignon et de le ministère de
l'intérieur comme ça a été fait
d'ailleurs sur covid une cellule qui va
regarder cas par cas d'appartement par
département quels sont les problèmes qui
se posent quels sont dans les
prioritaires de l'agriculture et
l'agroalimentation les Ultra
prioritaires enfin bref vous voyez bien
comment se fait ce genre de d'exercice
de priorité mais évidemment je vous
reconfle ce que j'ai dit y compris
ailleurs mais une fois qu'on l'a dit
c'est pas aussi simple que cela a
déployer parce que ça dépend de l'appel
d'énergie ça dépend du réseau comment il
est constitué à l'endroit où il y a
entreprise et donc c'est ça c'est
maintenant on essaie de regarder avec
les préfets départements de départ
département les endroits on peut avoir
un problème
nous remettant pas en cause la
philosophie que je développe que je
devais développe devant nous ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que c'est pas
simplement on a rien sur ces il suffit
pas de le dire après il faut essayer de
voir par capillarité comment ça se passe
concrètement et quels sont les
conséquences pour certains d'une j'étais
dans votre département à visiter une
usine de transformation de pommes de
terre pour faire des frites pour faire
pour dire un mot plus simple on connaît
tous les conséquences pour eux sont
d'une nature qui ne sont pas tout à fait
les mêmes que pour une filière laitière
et pour au passage dire qu'il y a un
certain nombre d’ailleurs d'opérateurs
qui ont fait je pense à la filière
betterave qui ont fait un gros effort
pour faire les appels d'énergie là
et pour avoir un cycle plus court pour
avoir moins besoin de l'appeler de
l'énergie au moment où il y a le plus de
risques et ce travail qui a été fait par
un certain nombre de piliers de filières
est à saluer c'est un travail de
responsabilité
donc c'est pas toujours comment
je finis sur deux ou trois sujets qui
ont été évoqués sur la filière alors je
partage mais on aura peut-être
l'occasion d'en reparler mais ce que
vous dites sur la nécessité de repenser
les modes de gestion repenser la forêt
repenser la mixité je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous mais il y a des gens
à qui va falloir expliquer qu'on va pas
planter des lettres
dans des territoires qui alors que le
hêtre est en voie de disparition sur le
territoire français donc la mixité va
falloir se mettre d'accord ce où elle
est possible parce que la réalité qui va
s'imposer à nous c'est le climat et le
sol
quand même faut se le dire parce que bon
bref allez je vais pas faire mes heures
de ma vie mais parfois il y a des
émissions il y a des gens qui vous
explique des choses qui sont un peu
théoriques
je sais pas ce que vous avez dit vous
non parce que je vous réponds le prenez
pas pour une attaque personnelle mais
mais c'est c'est assez simple de dire il
y a qu'à faucon sur ces sujets là je
rejoins ce que vous avez dit on a besoin
de renforcer les moyens de la recherche
parce qu'on a des sujets sur lesquels
sans doute depuis trop longtemps on n'a
pas mis assez de moyens pour savoir non
pas seulement documenté ce que va être
ce que vont être les effets du
dérèglement climatique mais quels sont
les bonnes essences aux bonnes endroits
comment on assure parfois de la mixité
comment on assure on a perdu en 15 ans
je crois de la moitié de notre capacité
de stockage carbone en forêt
et donc faut qu'on assume aussi que des
modalités et de gestion et de
replantation permettent de reconquérir
cette capacité de stockage carbone je
sais aussi les attentes de la société
donc il faut qu'on arrive à trouver un
point d'équilibre qui soit pas
simplement la caricature ce que je vois
très bien que le résineux va devenir la
victime explicatoire de la forêt comme
le maïs et la victime expiatoire des
sujets d'eau vous voyez et c'est parce
que vous faites mais je réponds quand
même à cette question en disant qu'il va
falloir qu'on essaie de poser
tranquillement les choses et de trouver
des solutions territoire par territoire
et donc on a besoin de documenter sur la
recherche ça me permet de dire deux
choses sur l'ONF par nature d'abord il y
a une nouvelle directrice comme l'a dit
votre présidente par nature le contrat
onef il était basé sur une trajectoire y
compris une trajectoire de moyens
humains par nature ça nécessite me
semble-t-il qu'on en discute
ne faites pas dire ce que j'ai pas dit
ça mérite qu'on leur dit vous me
demandez d'être comme ça audacieux en
commission
vous me la reposerez en séance mais
évidemment c'est le contrat d'objectif
c'est un contrat d'objectif et de moyens
dès lors qu'on dit que sur les moyens on
a des évolutions nouvelles alors après
moi je partage un peu alors je veux pas
travailler à la pensée de la présidente
la question des moyens n'est pas la
seule question la question c'est les
objectifs
oui non non parce qu'il faut il faut
qu'on dise quels sont les moyens sur
lequel ça me permet de répondre une
partie des 20 millions d'euros qui vont
être qui vont vous être proposés dans le
budget c'est des moyens qui sont pour du
matériel et c'est des moyens pour
permettre à l'ONU parce que qu'est-ce
qu'on a fait trop souvent non content et
c'est une trajectoire très longue chacun
porte sa part mais là la trajectoire est
assez longue sur le NF qu'est-ce qu'on a
fait c'est que ce content d'avoir fait
ça on lui a demandé des missions
supplémentaires or
elle a des missions supplémentaires et
va avoir des missions plus importantes
en particulier sur l'incendie donc ça
vise à couvrir les besoins qu'on va lui
demander sur la question de la
prévention des incendies pour aller dans
votre sens et des questions matérielles
et par ailleurs globalement il faut
qu'on se pose des questions que vous
êtes posé sur l'affaire des des
filières forestières sur le casse d'art
alors
j'ai dit tout à l'heure la chose
suivante je sais la question du plafond
ça c'est l'un des derniers marronniers
pardon d'expression ça n'est pas
péjoratif chez moi mais ça fait
longtemps que le casse d'art est une
question c'est une taxe affectée ça pose
toujours des questions c'est des sujets
budgétaires
ce que j'ai dit c'est qu'on est bien
dans le plafond et on renouvelle cette
question du plafond ce que j'ai dit tout
à l'heure c'est que les crédits qui ont
été en surplus cette année ils seront
bien redéployés sur 2023 pour déployer
des programmes de recherche parce qu'on
a besoin de recherche j'ajoute les
attire votre attention sur le fait qu'on
a besoin aussi ça me permet de répondre
à une question de la présidente de
mobiliser les crédits on va en mobiliser
avec ma collègue Sylvie Retailleau qui
travaille activement le sujet sur les
questions de la forêt au travers de
programme qu'on va soutenir qu'on va
essayer de soutenir au travers de France
c'est à dire qu'il y a pas que le casse
d'art France 2030 c'est des moyens qui
sont qui peuvent être colossaux ces 2,9
milliards d'euros forêt transition
agricole transition alimentaire qu'on
peut développer le plan protéines ce
qu'on a fait l'autre jour sur sur les
levures qu'on a été voir avec on était
inauguré si je peux dire avec avec
Sylvie Retailleau tout ça c'est des
moyens de recherche encore plus
puissants que les cadas mais ça ne doute
pas la question mais je veux dire
simplement que pour 2023 les reliquats
seront bien remis dans le casse
j'ai bien compris j'ai bien compris mais
c'est tout le sujet des taxes affectés
parce qu'après
oui très bien n'essayons oui mais là je
vous dis que ça fait que va permettre de
faire ça il me semble que c'est un
élément important et puis dernier point
la question du modèle agricole c'est la
question qui est devant nous ça me
permet de répondre aussi à la question
de la présidente mais je crois que j'ai
commencé à le faire sur la loi
d'orientation la question qu'il faut se
poser c'est la loi d'orientation et d'un
visant à la renouvellement des
générations c'est une loi qui doit poser
aussi les principes de quel est le
modèle alors j'ai du mal à dire le
modèle enfin moi le bon modèle c'est le
modèle qui va permettre à des
agriculteurs de résoudre les problèmes
alors ça c'est pas forcément cette loi
là mais la rémunération l'adaptation
changement climatique la nature des
filières et pas un modèle parce que
c'est
pardon ce manichéisme qu'on a parfois
vous l'avez pas eu mais je veux dire il
y a pas un modèle de d'agriculture il y
a des modèles qui sont sur des petites
structures il y en a qui nécessiteront
des moyens capitalistiques qui seront
plus importants et qu'il va falloir
accompagner enfin bref mais évidemment
c'est la question qu'il faut se poser la
question du modèle un modèle qui dont on
peut se dire que dans 30 ou 40 ans il
tient encore on peut penser c'est ça le
beau le mot modèle ou les bons modèles
qu'il faut déployer pardon madame la
Présidente mais je crois que j'ai
répondu à tout
c'était quoi votre dernière question
sur les filières élevage et chambre
froide est-ce qu'il y aura des aides à
priori plutôt qu'un poste je sais pas ce
que vous voulez dire dans les aides à
priori parce qu'à un moment il va
falloir
a priori a postérieux je sais ce que ça
veut dire
je me suis levé tôt mais j'ai encore un
petit peu de je sais pas si on peut en
débat ici mais non mais alors il y a
deux choses à faire alors je vais vous
dire il y a deux choses à faire la
première chose vous avez complètement
raison la première chose
on va être sur une aide guichet mais la
première chose qu'on a à dire c'est
qu'il y a beaucoup de d'imprévisibilité
pour les acteurs ils ont besoin de
savoir que de quelle dispositif et à
quel dispositif on va pouvoir émerger
c'est plutôt le ce qu'on appelle le
dispositif guichet auquel vous faites
référence vont pouvoir émerger pour moi
c'est une guichet et donc c'est plutôt à
faire on va travailler à faire en sorte
que le dispositif il puisse dire vous
rentrez ou pas dans les clous après
est-ce qu'on puisse on peut débloquer
vous savez que c'est compliqué quand
vous commencez à débloquer c'est ça
dépend si c'est 8 principes ou paiement
de principe
je suis d'accord mais moi je voulais
juste vous comprenez bien l'angoisse que
peut avoir aujourd'hui un produit mais
je comprends
est-ce qu'il met en route et ce qui
m'aide des bandes de poulet dans son
poulailler ça veut dire qu'il enclenche
le gaz l'électricité etc et qu'il aura
obligatoirement des factures de gaz et
d'électricité très élevé à cause de
l'augmentation d'énergie et on va lui
demander de devoir constater son déficit
avant de pouvoir l'aider
le troisième je parle du troisième
guichet pour celui-là qu'on est encore
en train de travailler parce qu'on a
besoin et je le dis au parlementaire que
vous êtes comme on l'a fait sur covid on
voit bien que parfois il est trop dans
la raquette donc il faut que j'assume
que il faut deuxième élément ça va être
géré par la DG FEEP qui a été très
efficace d'ailleurs dans la crise covid
donc c'est sur production de facture que
le versement donc c'est plutôt une forme
d'automaticité qui est gérée c'est
plutôt excenté qu'expose tout a priori
capostériori
très bien c'est l'épée de la monnaie
je crois que c'est l'épée de Damoclès
sur l'éligibilité à postérieur
j'ai bien compris
ah non non c'est pas le sujet non non
très bien je pense que d'ici pardon
d'ici le débat que nous aurons en séance
on aura des éléments plus qui vous plaît
parce que là on aura le guichet qui sera
ouvert et on aura les modalités très
bien merci avant de vous laisser la
parole je vais laisser la parole à
Vincent Segoin qui est le rapporteur
spécial la commission des finances
peut-être nous dire un mot sur ce point
de vue de la commission des finances
merci madame la Présidente beaucoup de
choses ont été dit Monsieur le Ministre
ravi de vous entendre
donc nous on a on a un paramètre au
niveau de la commission des finances on
a vu que les budgets en augmentation que
l'assurance récolte c'était un sujet sur
lequel vous avez répondu et par des
budgets certes qui sont pas au niveau
que mais mais en espérant que l'adhésion
soit au rendez-vous
je voulais surtout revenir sur sur le la
balance commerciale
on en parle beaucoup on en parle au
niveau de l'économie dans l'ensemble de
l'économie et c'est vrai que la balance
commerciale de l'agriculture était
excédentaire aujourd'hui elle est portée
uniquement par les vins et les
spiritueux
ce qui veut dire qu'on a fait on a perdu
du marché dans toutes les autres
productions
alors on le voit bien quand on utilise
ça de plus près on s'aperçoit que la
ferme France a perdu de la compétitivité
elle a un poids d'énorme qui pèse elle a
un coût du travail qui était levé alors
certes on met des mes collègues en ont
parfaitement parlé on met des procédures
mais qui sont pas pérennes alors c'est
quand même relativement compliqué pour
un jeune quand il s'installe de faire un
prévisionnel à trois ans ou à 5 ans et
on voit bien dans le taux de
remplacement que c'est que que on n'a
pas l'objectif atteint et que on a un
nombre d'exploitations qui diminue donc
je revenais on a des normes
franco-françaises des normes de
surtransposition on devait y mettre fin
j'ai pas l'impression qu'on est mis fin
on a de plus en plus l'impression et mes
collègues se sont très bien exprimés sur
le sujet que l'administration elle elle
condamne plus l'entreprise française que
par ces normes que les produits intrants
vous avez dit que vous étiez sensible et
que vous allez mettre les moyens en face
pour que les normes soient respectées
dans les que la clause miroir soit soit
respectée alors une question à ce sujet
là ça veut dire que les contrats de
libre-échange n'auront plus d'avenir ils
vont s'arrêter puisque le l'objectif des
contrats de libre-échange c'est
justement de pas de ne plus faire de
contrôle
voilà enfin il y a tout un ensemble de
questions qui est posée par le la
commission des finances sur l'ensemble
de ces sujets on a on est vraiment
inquiet par cette perte de compétitivité
de la ferme France et on voulait vous
entendre savoir comment vous allez entre
l'écologie
entre le pouvoir d'achat des Français et
les orientations et le développement de
l'économie agricole vous alliez
budgétisé et gérer des choses pour
l'avenir merci
beaucoup je pense qu'on va commencer la
série de questions vraiment je vous
demanderai cher collègues au-delà de ce
que je vous ai écrit de pas reposer des
questions que ont été déjà posées voilà
et qui nous ferait à tous perdre du
temps Daniel Laurent monsieur le
Président du Groupe 20 sera suivi de
Rémi Cardon madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre justement en amont
de la visite du président de la
République aux États-Unis début décembre
visant à souligner les liens économiques
forts entre de nos deux nations nous
avons souhaité au nom de la commission
des affaires économiques et du groupe
vignevin donc au signé avec Sophie
primat un courrier pour attirer
l'attention du Président de la
République sur le règlement définitif du
contentieux commercial aéronautique
qui subit plein fou que subit plein
fouet la filière viticole nous comptons
sur vous monsieur le ministre pour nous
soutenir et intervenir auprès du
président de la République parce que
pour que ce contentieux s'arrête parce
qu'il est en suspens il n'est pas arrêté
donc c'est dangereux pour la filière qui
est excédentaire vous avez entendu tout
à l'heure dans mon copain à Vincent
deuxième point les dégustations
gratuites de vins sont exonérées
d'assise en l'absence de transaction
commerciale cette tradition est remise
en cause selon l'administration sous la
représente entre 400 et 600000 euros de
droit exonérés quelle réponse
pouvez-vous apporter aux vignerons
deuxième question la loi pour assurer la
régulation de l'accès aux frontières
école au travers des structures
sociétaires est entré en vigueur or elle
est inapplicable en raison de la non
publication des décrets merci c'est
urgent troisième question dans les zones
insulaires atlantiques des projets de
transformation et commercialisation de
produits agricoles sont bloqués en
raison de la loi littorale ce qui
inquiète les agriculteurs inscrits dans
le maintien des activités agricoles il
faut que ces activités se considérées
dans le prolongement de l'acte de
production
j'espère que vous êtes d'accord avec moi
quatrième quatrième question
sur le projet de la belle bio pour le
sel les producteurs de sel marin de
l'Atlantique s'interroge les
négociations n'avancent pas et font
apparaître des positions antagonistes de
plusieurs pays de l'Union européenne les
petits producteurs attendent des
réponses concrètes je ne peux me de
votre éponge écrite du 3 novembre à une
question écrite qui n'apporte aucun
élément tangible donc merci de me faire
une réponse concrète et puis je
terminerai juste en évoquant ce qui a
été évoqué tout à l'heure concernant les
vétérinaires puisque j'ai été interpellé
moi aussi dans ma région par le
président des vétérinaires le maillage
sanitaire est en péril vous parliez tout
à l'heure
le maillage sanitaire est en péril donc
et surtout dans la ruralité merci Daniel
la parole est à Rémi Cardon et cette
fois-ci j'enclenche mon chronomètre
monsieur le ministre
habitant à proximité des hortillages
dans la Somme je vais faire un focus sur
les petites structures bio alternatives
et urbaines qui sont qui sont une
manière de mettre un peu d'urbanité dans
le monde agricole et de remettre au goût
du jour des pratiques culturales et de
favoriser les connexions entre le monde
rural et le le monde urbain elle
contribue à la sécurité alimentaire à la
création des liens sociaux et à la lutte
contre le changement climatique les
impacts économiques et environnementaux
sont indéniblesment positifs
malheureusement ces dispositifs d'aide
et de soutien sont
encore trop liés à la surface exploitée
donc ma question est la suivante avec ce
PLF que comptez-vous faire pour que les
nouvelles formes d'agriculture ne soient
pas qu'une variable d'ajustement dans la
pré-crise mais au contraire un levier de
résilience des petites des villes et de
la transition écologique autrement dit
est-ce que vous allez déconfiner un plan
résilience sur des petites structures
alternatives bio je prends le mot que
vous avez employé tout à l'heure
merci beaucoup la parole est à madame la
présidente du groupe forêt du groupe
d'études forêts Anne-Catherine Loisier
puis ensuite à Fabien gay merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur ministre alors
d'abord pour compléter les propos de mon
collègue Jean-Claude Tissot avec
lesquels je suis en parfaite accords
notamment sur la nécessité de revoir le
contrat d'objectif onfa donc dans ce
proche de finance monsieur le ministre
donc le gouvernement acte sa décision de
revenir en fait sur les suppressions de
postes à l'ONF
et donc il lance par contre d'après ce
que j'ai compris non financer rêve 60 et
il en laisserait 20 à la charge de l'ONF
donc si vous pouvez nous expliquer
pourquoi puisque malheureusement on le
sait sauf adores exceptions jamais le
budget de l'ONF c'est-à-dire les
recettes issues des ventes n'ont permis
d'atteindre un équilibre budgétaire donc
comment vont-ils financer ces 20 postes
sauf à faire des restrictions par
ailleurs et puis qu'en est-il de la
forêt privée puisque la forêt public
c'est certes 5 millions d'HECT en
métropole mais la forêt privée c'est 12
millions d'hectares et qui
malheureusement ont été largement
victimes des incendies donc comment
venir accompagner une structuration une
meilleure gestion dans la forêt privée
dans ce budget visiblement il y a un
changement de plafond de TP sur le CNPF
mais qui n'est pas accompagné de
financement a priori donc voilà quels
sont vos propositions en ce sens et puis
tant que j'ai la parole je voulais juste
un petit topo sur le volet de l'élevage
vous avez parlé sur le ministre du
malaise des agriculteurs grandissant et
donc qu'en est-il aujourd'hui des
réponses qu'on peut apporter à ces
agriculteurs effectivement en matière de
cause miroir vous en avez parlé mais on
voit pas forcément beaucoup d'éléments
concrets sur le terrain qu'en est-il des
traités de libre-échange puisqu'on
entend dire que il réapparaîtrait dans
le premier trimestre 2023 donc Mercosur
Australie Mexique avec on le sait des
contingents de viande bovine important
et enfin qu'en est-il de d'une fameuse
directive enfin d'une directive qui
serait étudié aujourd'hui à ce jour au
Parlement européen qui consisterait à
inclure les petits élevages de 158 GB
sous le régime des ICPE donc là autant
dire qu'en tant que contrainte je pense
que nos agriculteurs vont être chargés
d'un fardeau qui va vraiment les
préoccuper merci monsieur le ministre
Fabien gay suivi de France montauget
merci madame la Présidente bonjour
monsieur ministre de l'Agriculture à la
sécurité alimentaire le la sécurité
alimentaire étant extrêmement importante
moi je juge vous interroge sur un aspect
comment on peut parler de sécurité
alimentaire lorsqu'on est en train de
continuer à signer à tour de bras des
traités libre-échange qui mettent en
difficulté nos propres agriculteurs
agricultrices dans une compétition
déloyale des loyal au moins 10 ans
social et environnementales
donc j'ai deux questions précises je
veux pas être trop long quand c'est
qu'on aura le débat sur le CETA vous
avez été quand même ministre des
Relations et le Parlement et vous et
vous ne l'avez pas inscrit à l'ordre du
jour je rappelle quand même que c'est le
gouvernement qui a la main sur cette
question là donc vous avez fait un choix
et en tant que ministre de ne pas le
mettre sur la table ici au Sénat
pourquoi et quand et comment je rappelle
que nous avons voté une proposition de
résolution à l'unanimité moins quelques
abstention pour inscrire alors du jour
et la deuxième chose c'est que la
dernière semaine de la présidence de la
France de la Commission européenne la
Nouvelle-Zélande et là comme c'est un
accord de seconde génération mais que
l'ensemble des gouvernements maintenant
ça lave les mêmes parce que personne ne
voit que à chaque fois que ça parle
devant les parlements nationaux c'est
compliqué donc du coup retrait et on
n'aura pas le droit d'avoir un débat sur
le traité avec la Nouvelle-Zélande donc
est-ce que vous en tant que ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la sécurité
alimentaire vous êtes favorable à ce que
l'ensemble des traités libre-échange
passe et soit ratifié devant les
parlements nationaux voilà je vous
remercie merci beaucoup Fabien la parole
est à Frank honte j'ai ensuite à
Jean-Pierre Moga merci madame la
Présidente merci monsieur le ministre à
trois sujets très rapidement d'abord le
sujet de l'eau tous nos départements
sont concernés le mien le Gers de
manière de manière importante vous le
vous le savez dans ce budget il y a des
crédits d'investissement qui seront
fléchés utilisés à cet effet je pense
que la
la problématique extrêmement compliquée
de l'eau ne serait ne se résoudra pas
exclusivement avec des investissements
et qu'il faut aussi des démarches
territoriales pour aller dans le bon
sens et parmi ces démarches il y en a
une qui a été déployée il y a 3 ans et
demi qui viennent de faire l'objet d'une
evaluation c'est celle des projets
territoriaux de gestion de l'eau les
ptge les fameux PT ge qui ont été lancés
je crois en 2000 en 2019
un rapport vient d'être rendu par les
conseils généraux à la management du au
développement durable et et à
l'agriculture et l'espace rural je sais
pas si vous en avez eu connaissance il
est il est très très intéressant et en
substance il dit je partage ça que c'est
dans une approche collective d'emblée de
l'ensemble des parties prenantes à
l'échelle des bassins hydrographiques
qu'on arrivera à progresser et et
peut-être à éviter des situations de
blocage tels qu'on les connaît
aujourd'hui et dont on ne sait pas se
sortir quand on y a dedans quoi pour
dire les choses clairement alors que les
agriculteurs ont besoin d'investissement
pour justement par rapport à l'eau qui
leur est absolument nécessaire sans
compter les autres usagers de l'eau qui
doivent être évidemment aussi prendre
pris en compte donc je voulais vous
demander quels sont vos intentions à cet
égard l'influence aviaire que vous avez
évoqué qui touche aussi hélasme mon
département je voudrais vous faire
passer un message il faut aussi protéger
les modes d'élevage autarciques les
petits il faut pas les faire disparaître
si c'est le cas s'il disparaissent
d'abord pour eux c'est dramatique et je
peux vous dire que je rencontre moi des
éleveurs ampleur par rapport à cette
question là ils sont très très inquiets
par rapport à à la sauce entre
guillemets à laquelle ils vont être
mangés à cet égard et et c'est ce sont
des vecteurs d'images positives pour nos
territoires là où ils sont et évidemment
de qualité et scientifiquement il n'a
pas été démontré que ce type d'élevage
était à l'origine d'infections donc
voilà je voudrais avoir votre avis
là-dessus le dernier point hyper rapide
vous avez parlé des assurances et je
partage voilà tout ce qui a été fait on
a voté les textes etc il y a pas de
problème par rapport à ça comment
allez-vous vous arranger de la fameuse
moyenne olympique qui renvoie aux règles
de l'OMC et qui reste qui risque d'être
un facteur de non compréhension et de
non-adhésion des agriculteurs à la
démarche assuranielle merci merci Franck
Jean-Pierre Maugat ensuite Henri Cabanel
merci madame la présidente madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre je
souhaite vous poser deux questions comme
vous le savez nos territoires et
particulièrement le miel le
Lot-et-Garonne que vous connaissez bien
sont de plus en plus touchés par des
épisodes de gel au printemps et de
sécheresse en été ces derniers sont
dévastateurs pour les cultures et
provoque des pertes importantes de
récoltes comme c'est malheureusement
encore le cas cette année sur les
productions de pruneaux dans mon
département de noisette pour la
l'arboriculture etc dans ce contexte
quel accompagnement l'État
et les producteurs les producteurs
pardon peuvent-ils attendre de l'État
compte tenu du dérèglement climatique
ces aléas vont être amenés à se
reproduire plus fréquemment de leur mon
collègue parlé de la moyenne olympique
quel cadre pérenne peut-être mis en
place pour soutenir nos agriculteurs et
lutter contre l'irrégularité pardon
croissante des récoltes deuxièmement je
souhaitais vous interroger au studio au
sujet du stockage de l'eau je conviens
tout à fait que cela ne relève pas
entièrement de votre périmètre mais la
vie du ministre de l'agriculture et de
la souveraineté alimentaire est
essentielle sur cette question comment
notre agriculture va-t-elle s'adapter
aux déficitrique de plus en plus
fréquent monsieur le ministre quel est
votre opinion sur le stockage de l'eau
par retenu colinéaire
de manière plus générale comment peut-on
selon vous lutter contre l'impact de ces
dérèglements hydriques
comment peut-on préparer sur le plan
budgétaire
et que prévoyez-vous sur sur ce plan à
court et en moyenne terme enfin
pensez-vous qu'une mutation des cultures
est inévitable je vous remercie
juste dans les temps Henri Cabanel
ensuite Jean-Jacques Michaud merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je vais revenir quelques
instants sur ce cas évoqué ma collègue
Françoise Ferrat contre sur le mal-être
des agriculteurs donc elle vous
demandait la feuille de route de la mise
en œuvre de ces
de la volonté de votre prédécesseur avec
une enveloppe que vous avez donc que
vous avez annoncé et vous avez nommé un
coordinateur monsieur Lenoir qui est en
charge donc de mettre en place
ce qui était prévu c'était
2022 une cellule départementale dans
chaque département donc apparemment il y
a un peu de retard j'aimerais savoir
pourquoi il y a autant de retard alors
que vous avez eu un âme pour le mettre
en place j'avais déposé la main de
manche demain sur la volonté de créer un
observatoire justement sur ces mesures
qui a été jugé et recevable mais je
voudrais vous entendre sur ce sujet
puisque l'actuel ministre de l'économie
qui était à l'époque au ministre de
l'agriculture en 2012 avait déjà pris
donc des mesures pour ce mal-être mais
il a fallu attendre 10 ans pour voir que
effectivement ce n'est ça ne
correspondait pas peut-être à la réalité
donc je voudrais savoir si
éventuellement il est possible de mettre
en place donc un observatoire pour
effectivement limiter donc les impacts
de ce mal-être vous avez évoqué aussi
l'installation et notre problème
effectivement c'est que pour une
excellation il y a deux à trois départs
à la retraite et il faut effectivement
trouver des moyens vous avez pris
des mesures concernant la transmission
je n'y reviendrai pas en passant donc de
300 à 500000 euros le plafond
d'exonération des droits de mutation
mais le problème majeur au-delà du
revenu que vous avez évoqué qui n'est
pas très attractif pour la nouvelle
génération c'est un problème de foncier
et sur le foncier moi je voudrais vous
entendre sur les affaires qui sont
légitimes sur ce foncier et les moyens
que l'on qu'elles n'ont pas suffisamment
en
Occitanie dans notre région et je
remercie donc la présidente Delga elle a
mis en place donc un système de portage
financier mais toutes les régions ne
sont pas dans ce système là donc moi
j'avais émis l'idée à l'époque que les
établissements publics fonciers est une
partie de leur impôts donc fléchés sur
les affaires qu'en pensez-vous
merci beaucoup
ensuite la présidente Marie-Christine
Chauvin
monsieur le ministre je souhaiterais
attirer votre attention sur deux sujets
qui m'ont été rapportés par les actes
par les agriculteurs de mon territoire
et je vous parlerai pas de prédation ce
soir le premier ça c'est quand même le
sujet de l'élevage et parce que les
éleveurs ont été surpris d'apprendre la
non prise en compte pour les icchen des
surfaces collectives dans la mise en
œuvre de l'éco-régime pour les
exploitations transhumantes ça porte sur
quand même un quart de la surface
transhuman des Pyrénées c'est 4000
éleveurs et 20 millions d'euros qui sont
en jeu là-dessus
le deuxième qui est de la même veine
c'est l'introduction d'un critère de
chargement plancher à 0,2
UGB par hectare et ceci est un
chargement qui est impossible sur
certains sur certaines territoires le
deuxième point c'est plutôt par rapport
à la grippe à vierge c'est sur des il
est prévu dans le PLF une enveloppe d'un
milliard d'euros vous l'avez dit pour la
gestion de cette grille et je voulais
attirer votre attention sur les
producteurs de palmipède notamment en
occitane ni qui pourrait être exclu de
l'aide compensatoire parce que c'était
de ne viserait que les producteurs
situés en zone touchée directement et
vous l'avez dit les fournisseurs de
canetons sont implantés dans l'ouest de
la France et il y a bon nombre
d'agriculteurs qui eux sont ailleurs que
dans les zones directement touchées qui
ne peuvent pas travailler voilà un petit
peu les deux questions que je voulais
vous poser merci beaucoup Jean-Jacques
la présence du groupe d'études d'élevage
Marie-Christine Chauvin ensuite Amel
gaker
merci présidente monsieur le ministre
j'aurais vous avez entendu l'élevage
revient souvent donc j'aurai également
de nombreuses questions à vous poser
c'est pourquoi je me permettrai de vous
inviter à venir rencontrer le groupe
d'études élevage une fois le budget
passé bien sûr mais je pense que ce
temps de partage serait très important
ma question de ce jour est relative à la
crise de la surproduction que connaît la
filière porcine bio comme d'autres
filières bio d'ailleurs mais à ce jour
les 700 producteurs de por bio font face
à des difficultés conjonctuelles
importantes leur surproduction est
évaluée à 25 voire 30% par rapport à la
demande le marché allemand c'est
également tassé alors évidemment dans le
même temps le cours moyen du port du
port inconnu une envolée spectaculaire
en 2022 et dans ce contexte il serait
tentant de croire que cette filière
porcine est en très bonne santé et en
réalité ce n'est que partiellement le
cas et ce n'est pas le cas de la filière
bio donc des groupements et des
producteurs de cette filière bio qui
appelle à l'aide car ils font face à des
problématiques spécifiques alors
Monsieur le Ministre ma question est
très simple quelle solution
entendez-vous apporter à ces producteurs
sous quelle forme dans quel délai est-ce
des aides d'urgence et un plan
d'accompagnement pour un passage
momentané ou définitif à la filière
porcine traditionnelle je pense que
c'est également une façon d'envisager
les choses et pour ceux qui sont près de
la retraite comment les accompagner sur
un plan de cessation d'activité je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre merci
beaucoup madame la Présidente Amel gaker
ensuite pierre lourd
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre dans ce contexte d'explosion du
coup de l'énergie c'est la situation de
la filière en d'hiver que je souhaite
évoquer
je pourrais parler des arboriculteurs
des éleveurs des producteurs de pommes
de terre également sous tension mais la
situation des andiers plus alarmante car
particulièrement énergivore en
électricité il n'est plus question
d'urgence mais de survie de la filière
et de milliers d'emplois la situation
est insoutenable notamment pour 30% des
producteurs qui aujourd'hui sont en
situation de renégociation de leur
contrat d'électricité pour exemple je
vais vous citer la situation d'un
producteur dans la facture est passée de
150000 euros en 2021 à 300.000 euros en
2022 à 800.000 euros en 2023 je sais que
vous êtes à l'écoute et en contact avec
cette filière vous avez annoncé
récemment l'application d'un amortisseur
électricité par contre une mesure
insuffisante complexe et surtout qui ne
permet pas
les semaines à venir les mois à venir de
manière sereine selon les producteurs
concernés donc au-delà de dispositifs de
soutien inadaptés à la situation des
filières très énergivores peut-on aller
urgemment vers un plan pérenne de survie
simple pérenne comme je le disais et qui
permettra en tout cas à ces filières de
passer les quelques semaines à venir je
vous remercie merci beaucoup Amel pierre
bouh ensuite Daniel salmon
monsieur le ministre on a déjà évoqué
les contrôles qui se multiplient auprès
des agriculteurs français
à travers la DRAC la DDA la ddp love
ainsi de suite et qui est en complet
déséquilibre par rapport aux produits
importés en gros 3000 agents pour sur le
dos des agriculteurs français
300 pour contrôler les produits qui
rentrent en France avec des scandales
bien connus sur le sésame et ainsi de
suite je voulais vous proposer tout
simplement de rétablir l'équilibre vous
en enlevez 101200 sur les agriculteurs
et vous les mettez en contrôle des
produits entrants est-ce que c'est
possible pour vous
pierre de la brièveté Daniel salmon Sud
Bernard
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire j'insiste sur
ce point j'aborde j'aimerais savoir
quelle différence vous faites entre
souveraineté alimentaire et
autosuffisance alimentaire parce que
j'ai l'impression que dans l'esprit de
certains cela se confond un peu
et sinon allons sur l'agriculture bio
qui a le souci elle du lien à la terre
qui a un souci qui est vraiment une
agriculture résiliente et je pense que
cette
filière qui était en difficulté
elle est tout à fait à même de répondre
au défi du réchauffement climatique et
de l'effondrement de la biodiversité et
je trouve que vous n'avez pas envoyé
dans le PLF 2023 un signal fort à cette
à cette filière qui en a vraiment besoin
vous avez dit tout à l'heure pas
d'interdiction sans solution ça
m'inquiète un petit peu c'est à dire il
y a un moment faut faire des priorités
aussi que pensez-vous de la lutte pour
éviter la disparition des Pollin
réalisateur je pense que là il y a
peut-être un sujet de priorité sinon
nombreuses questions étaient posées
concernant l'affianza arrière
quelle est la responsabilité de la
filière d'élevage intensif est-ce qu'il
y a des vraies études épidémiologiques
aujourd'hui on sait que tous les petits
éleveurs payent très cher les éleveurs
en plein air également et bien est-ce
qu'on a des vraies études sur le sur le
sujet donc je vais me contenter de ces
questions là pour l'instant merci et
surtout que j'ai plus de temps merci
Daniel
Bernard buis pardon excuse-moi merci
présidente monsieur le ministre
rapidement trois questions la première
puisqu'elle a pas été posée concerne la
prédation dans la Drôme cette année les
attaques de loups à l'envers des brebis
ont été en explosion puisque 860 brebis
sont perdus et je passe aussi les autres
bêtes donc il y a des attentes fortes du
monde agricole je sais qu'on va avoir un
nouveau plan donc je pense que là dedans
il va falloir vraiment avancer
sérieusement en ce qui concerne
notamment la protection des chiens
troupeau avec le seuil minimal de bête
pour que l'espèce soit viable qui avait
été fixée à 500 donc comment arriver à
cette régulation et puis envisager à
terme le déclassement du loup dans la
convention de Berne ma deuxième question
porte sur le chèque alimentaire l'idée
telle toujours en train de germer
peut-on espérer récolter sa mise en
oeuvre courant 2023
enfin ma dernière question porte sur la
situation des syndicats d'irrigation
donc en Drôme premier département
agricole d'Auvergne Rhône-Alpes le
syndicat d'irrigation m'interpelle sur
la flambée du prix de l'électricité
indispensable pour pouvoir pomper l'eau
et l'envoyer sous pression dans les
parcelles cultivées il semblerait que
les aides annoncées par le gouvernement
pour les collectivités ne permettent pas
ou mal aux syndicat d'irrigation
d'absorber le choc y a-t-il un trou dans
la raquette si tel est le cas que
peut-on faire en période budgétaire pour
leur apporter une solution au jour du
malgré les aides renforcer le coût de
l'irrigation à l'hectare serait
multipliée par 4 ou 5 et ne permettrait
plus une rentabilité de la parcelle
aujourd'hui des agriculteurs d'un visage
carrément pas de semer vu les prix
annoncés merci beaucoup je présente mes
excuses à Dominique Serge et Yves que
j'avais zappé dans la liste donc
Dominique Estrosi Cesson avec mes
excuses
alors néanmoins madame la Présidente je
vais être amené à imposer un petit peu
les mêmes questions mais je vais quand
même le faire que Bernard buis puisque
je voulais parler de la prédation
également à Monsieur le Ministre le
seuil de survie de l'espèce qui est fixé
à 500 individus est atteint depuis
longtemps l'Office français de la
biodiversité en dénombré 921 en juin
dernier il convient maintenant de
maintenir de contenir sa prolifération
au risque que le Plan National loue
2018-2023 et les activités d'élevage ne
se transforment dans sa prochaine
mouture 2023 2028 en un plan de
sauvegarde des femmes et des hommes qui
produisent notre alimentation préserve
et entretiennent notre environnement
alors qu'elles vont être monsieur le
ministre vos propositions pour lutter
contre la surpopulation des loups qui ne
me permet pas une cohabitation avec le
pastoralisme il y a urgence à agir face
à l'extension massive des territoires
qu'occupent les loups devant la
commission des affaires économiques de
l'Assemblée nationale le 21 septembre
dernier vous avez expliqué que le statut
du loup doit évoluer rapidement compte
tenu de la menace vous avez rappelé la
nécessaire négociation européenne et que
vous lanceriez fin septembre au nom de
la France avec l'Union européenne alors
pouvez-vous nous dire où en sont ces
négociations pour obtenir le
déclassement du loup d'espèces super
protégés à protéger et enfin
dernièrement dans notre hémicycle lors
d'une séance de questions d'actualité
vous avez annoncé la création d'une
seconde brigade loup c'est très
important effectivement alors cette
seconde brigade loup est-ce qu'elle est
présente dans le PLF est-ce qu'il y a
des crédits qui existent déjà ou sinon
par quels moyens financier sera-t-elle
créée et enfin sur toujours en lien
aussi quand même avec le pastoralisme
dans mon département les éleveurs
fromagers subissent eux aussi une
importante augmentation de leur facture
énergétique et d'explosion des coûts et
puis le pour le bétail malgré tout
l'énergie pour faire fonctionner les
infrastructures l'énergie pour la
conservation froide les coûts de
livraison augmentent comme augmentent
les coûts pour les entreprises les PME
les collectivités qui bénéficient elles
déjà d'une aide de l'État alors quelle
mesure de soutien peuvent envisager ces
éleveurs fromagers qui font déjà qui
sont déjà durement touchés par la
prédation dans mon département merci
Dominique Serge mériou ensuite Yves
Bouloux
d'abord j'ai noté
l'appellation de souveraineté
alimentaire ministre de l'Agriculture et
de la souveraineté alimentaire ce qui
pour moi est important j'espère que
c'est pas que des mots mais je fais je
fais confiance parce que je pense que la
souveraineté alimentaire c'est un
problème auquel on va être confronté
dans les
années à venir en moyenne terme si on ne
prend pas garde à la dérive sur laquelle
on est parti on l'a noté dans le rapport
avec Laurent Duplomb et
Pierre Louroux on a quand même une
inquiétude d'une phrase qui
exporte de moins en moins qui est passé
du deuxième rang au cinquième rang
mondial et le France qui importe de plus
en plus
la moitié de des produits consommés en
France pratiquement provient de
l'importation ce qui est quand même un
signe très inquiétant
ça vient effectivement d'une perte de
compétitivité l'agriculture française je
vais pas revenir sur les causes qui sont
multifactorielles qui ont été qui ont
été largement évoqués mais ça se fait au
prix d'un triple manquement d'abord pour
les agriculteurs auxquels on a du mal à
rémunérer la fonction de production mais
c'est quand même un vrai problème
d'abord pour les consommateurs aussi
notamment pour les catégories sociales
les plus défavorisées qui
compte tenu des problèmes de pouvoir
d'achat n'ont pas accès à une
alimentation française de qualité mais
doivent se retourner vers une
alimentation souvent importée et de
qualité parfois médiocres parce qu'elle
n'est absolument pas contrôlée
moi je voulais évoquer bien sûr sur les
questions d'irrigation mais à
l'irrigation parce que dans le Sud-Ouest
il n'y a pas d'agriculture sans eau et
il n'y a pas de production sans eau il
n'y a pas de qualité du produit sans eau
alors moi je l'aborderai plutôt sur sur
le problème des des grosses retenues
colinéaires qui permettent de de
soutenir les tiages des rivières et
parce que je pense que c'est retenu
peuvent être un support de la
biodiversité on a ce cet exemple en
Dordogne avec une rivière sur lequel on
a un barrage qui a été fait et une
réserve il y a une vingtaine d'années et
on maintient donc la biodiversité
donc je voudrais vraiment qu'on le
présente en positif et en dernier point
sur le chèque alimentaire je passe sur
tous les autres points parce que je vois
que ça presse mais sur le chèque
alimentaire est-ce qu'on pourrait
contourner les les
la distribution et regarder s'il y a pas
moyen avons travaillé avec des
organisations caritatives qui pourraient
être ceux qui connaissent bien le public
en difficulté etc etc
c'est pas dans le budget il veut Boulou
ensuite ensuite ensuite ensuite
Sébastien plat
il y en a beaucoup vous avez du succès
monsieur le ministre madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre
il s'agit de retraite de retraite
agricole
le calcul des retraites des agriculteurs
sur celles des salariés et des
indépendants
et notamment via le calcul de la
retraite sur les seuls 25 meilleures
années de revenus merci
beaucoup je vous demande d'être encore
plus rapide parce que le ministre doit
nous quitter à 19h55
et c'est le président l'archet qui
l'attend donc il allait voilà 18h55 mais
il faut qu'il réponde quand même donc
voilà
ce ministre brillante j’éprouve quelques
difficultés à percevoir la trajectoire
novatrice de ce budget que vous nous
proposez puisqu'on prend on prend les
mêmes les mêmes mesures et on recommence
j'ai l'intention de dire mais bon la
question qui est centrale et moi qui je
vous pose c'est quelle quelle est la
stratégie de développement agricole que
vous souhaitez dans un contexte
budgétaire tendu puisque l'endettement
de l'État est très élevé et puis nous
sommes dans le contexte des armements
fiscal ensuite la pérennisation du Tod
c'est une très bonne chose l'assurance
MRC aussi mais j'aimerais être rassuré
sur le fait que les compagnies
d'assurance seront en capacité de la
mettre en oeuvre dès 2023 et comment
surtout comptez-vous vous attaquer très
directement la question de la moyenne
olympique qui constituent un fromageur
je donne un exemple moi je suis vigneron
ma moyenne olympique après 3 années de
grêle et de gel l'état veinct de litres
hectares donc j'ai aucun intérêt à
m'assurer et c'est un vrai majeur
aujourd'hui à la mise en oeuvre de la de
la MRC en particulier sur sur nos types
de culture et enfin une dernière
question sur les abattoirs de proximité
dans nos massifs qui sont en grande
difficulté
à la fois pour des contraintes
sanitaires et surtout des moyens
financiers les ont un rôle structurant
dans nos montagnes ils sont portés à
bout de bras par les collectivités
locales mais ça suffit pas donc comment
vous niveau de l'État comptez-vous les
accompagner merci
merci beaucoup Franck mais non-ville
ensuite Christian Redon sarrazzi merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre quand on arrive à 7h vivement
dans le dans le rythme des questions
beaucoup de sujets ont été ont été
évoqués théodde je voulais évoquer aussi
le la multirisque agricole et notamment
le niveau de de préparation des des
assureurs
alors moi je me concentre reste plutôt
sur la partie du coût de l'énergie et ça
vient peut-être en complément de notre
collègue
Amel gaccare
effectivement il y a eu
[Musique]
de 70 euros par mégawattheure qui est en
phase de de
renégociation et malgré le malgré les
dispositions
subiraient une hausse de 400 %, donc
juste vraiment
très difficile à supporter pour ce style
de production merci merci Franck
Christian redon-sarrazzi pierre Cuypers
de monsieur le ministre je souhaitais
évoquer avec vous la situation du
renouvellement des générations mais pas
de agriculteurs de ceux des vétérinaires
qu'on a déjà un peu évoqué afin que le
ministre d'agriculture qui se remporte
en 2030 de se trouve pas dans la
situation que connaît aujourd'hui votre
collègue de la santé il est absolument
nécessaire de prendre dès à présent les
bonnes décisions vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir qu'il y a un projet sur ce sujet
en nouvelle-aquitaine région où les
filières animales sont très présentes et
le problème sanitaire assez prégnant
l'influence air dans le Sud-Ouest y est
pour beaucoup la santé animale et la
santé humaine sont indissociables
c'est le cœur du projet d'école
vétérinaire que porte donc la région à
Limoges wannels donc une seule santé ce
n'est pas seulement une école c'est tout
un écosystème avec les praticiens
vétérinaires les formations médicales
humaines les écoles d'agro les
formations universitaires et de
laboratoires associés donc en biologie
en sciences de la vie et de la santé les
entreprises du secteur monsieur le
ministre êtes-vous prêt donc à
accompagner ce projet et lui donner les
moyens nécessaires aux côtés de la
région nouvelle Aquitaine et de tous les
acteurs territoriaux merci beaucoup
Christian pierre creeper sans suite
Laurent saumon merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre
la Commission européenne veut supprimer
l'utilisation d'un herbicide utilisée
sur la culture de l'endive de la
chicorée et du haricot ce produit
s'appelle le bon allant il a pour
matière active la bacturaline qui doit
perdre son autorisation d'utilisation
prochainement la Commission européenne a
demandé à chaque État membre de se
prononcer avant le 4 novembre dernier
j'aimerais avoir votre réponse par
rapport à cette interrogation
communautaire sachant que si ce produit
est supprimé si la France ne l'autorise
pas la production n'a pas de produits de
remplacement donc nous sommes dans une
situation de perte de production
d'endives ça se rajoute conditions
énergétiques etc où les coûts
énergétiques vont cinq fois plus x 5 x 6
mais c'est vrai pour la production de
pommes c'est vrai pour la production de
pommes de terre et puis une dernière
question nous abordons en 2023 la
dernière utilisation de dérogation des
néonicotinoïdes sur la betterave
sucrière
quel est votre position pour 2023 sur sa
reconduction enfin pour son efficacité
et pour 2024 sachant que nous n'avons
pas aujourd'hui de produits de
remplacement qui soit efficace merci
merci Pierre Laurent saumon suite
et cartonnerie malgré une revalorisation
des prix par les industriels au compte
tenu l'inflation de suivi ces derniers
les surfaces vont passer de 23500
hectares avaient en 2021 à 18700
possiblesment en 2022 donc mes questions
c'est de savoir si vous allez aider
cette filière par une aide
conjoncturelle c'est-à-dire une aide
directe à la production comme il la
demande de si il va y avoir une aide
structurelle dans le cadre des écorriges
et de leur permettre d'obtenir compte
tenu de la production de protéines de
pommes de terre de pouvoir avoir un
point supplémentaire dans le cas des
écorigines de faciliter la production de
pommes de terre spéculer a notamment en
termes d'irrigation à savoir la
réutilisation des eaux chargées
résiduelles donc issus des situations
d'épuration par exemple
de l'usine elle-même et puis enfin
d'intégrer l'activité régulière dans des
dispositifs de modernisation d'outils
industriels ça c'était ma première
question la plus importante ne revient
pas sur les endivis mais j'ai déjà
sollicité vos services à ce sujet qui
sont véritablement grande difficulté et
enfin une dernière petite question c'est
que pensez-vous d'être décapitalisation
de l'élevage et des risques qu'il y aura
demain sur les entrants dans les usines
dans les unités de méthanisation
merci beaucoup Laurent Micheline Jacques
merci madame le Président Monsieur le
ministre vous avez annoncé dans votre
propos liminaire une augmentation des
crédits pour soutenir l'agriculture
ultramarine et je m'en réjouis le plan
chlordécone 2021 2027 oriente plus
particulièrement la Rochelle la
recherche sur la compréhension de
l'évolution de cette molécule dans la
nature et vente et éventuelles les
éventuelles méthodes de décontamination
quelle place prévoyez-vous de faire à la
diversification de la production que
pensez-vous du colza pour l'usage de la
chimie verte en vue de faire des
Outre-mer des territoires d'innovation
très bien je vous remercie j'ai une
dernière question de la part d'Olivier
Ritman mais je suis sûr que vous la
devinez sur le décret d'application de
la loi sans passe tout si vous a
beaucoup sollicité sur le sujet
il semblerait que le décret
d'application avant de passer au Conseil
d'État soit déjà dans la presse donc je
voulais avoir quelques informations sur
ce décret d'application de la loi sans
passe tous auquel nous regardons avec
beaucoup d'attention
merci vous avez donc 27 minutes
mais je vous ferai un mot pour le
Président
je commence par les quatre sujets qui
sont revenus à plusieurs motifs c'est
pour éviter d'y revenir
au prédation accords de libre-échange
question alimentaire et notamment le
chèque parce qu'il me semble que c'est
des éléments qui reviennent à plusieurs
reprises je sens que le monsieur gay
aimerait bien que je réponde tout de
suite sur la question du libre-échange
alors il y a plusieurs sujets il y a la
méthode et puis il y a le fond des
questions ça a été posée par un certain
nombre d'entre vous et puis après la
question de l'application je vous donne
ce que je pense du sujet d'abord on a un
sujet global de méthode d'approche sur
les accords de libre-échange je vous
disiez monsieur sénateur si on fait la
réciprocité stricte il y aura plus
l'accord de libre-échange votre voisin
de deux rangs disait il faut quand même
préserver
le commerce du vin et spiritueux et donc
il faut lever les contraintes des
Américains alors il me semble qu'il va
falloir qu'on se mette pardon je le dis
un peu à bruptement d'accord dans ce
pays soit on veut exportateur si on veut
plus être exportateur mais on pourra pas
être là sans l'autre
le libre-échange s'accepte que nous
puissions exporter donc c'est des
questions de compétitivité que ce que
souligne monsieur Dupont et le
distorsion qui sont pour beaucoup
d'entre elles c'est un élément qu'on
aura débattre à l'issue de vos de votre
rapport que vous avez fait avec d'autres
collègues du de cette commission souvent
la concurrence elle est
intracommunautaires et le terrain qu'on
a perdu il est souvent
intracommunautaire donc c'est pas les
accords de libre-échange de soit on a
décidé de plus vendre de lait plus
vendre de céréales plus vendent de vins
et spiritueux mais il faudra pas
demander à ceux à qui on le vend
de que eux ne puissent pas faire du
commerce avec nous quand nous nous
pourrions nous aurions droit de faire du
commerce avec ça marchera pas comme ça
donc il va falloir juste il va falloir
se le dire deuxième élément pour
répondre mais c'est là avec l'autre
c'est pas l'un sans l'autre je suis
désolé de le dire comme ça parce qu'il
faut que c'est une question de cohérence
si on veut on est tous à regretter la
perte de souveraineté française en
disant à l'époque nous exportions des
fruits et légumes nous exportions du
sucre nous exportions et nous le faisons
plus pour savoir
j'irai après parce que ça me donne donc
on a besoin premièrement c'est celui-là
moi je pense qu'on doit assumer une
capacité exportatrice ça me permet quand
même de répondre à la question du
sénateur seulement si j'ai pas de
mémoire sur
souvreté autarcie
autosuffisance j'ai entendu au taxi
dans un modèle de dérèglement climatique
excusez-moi je veux dire un truc qui est
un peu peut-être ballot mais si vous
dites j'ai besoin de sang je produis
sans quand vous avez une année comme
celle-là vous faites comment
ma grand-mère disait pour en avoir assez
il faut en avoir trop je dis la même
chose mais vous
donc un moment dans un modèle de
dérèglement climatique on a besoin
d'échange à un moment quand monsieur
Poutine fait de l'alimentation une arme
alimentaire et qui décide de bloquer les
ports on a besoin d'en avoir un peu plus
pour en donner un à d'autres
mais si autosuffisant c'est que je
couvre simplement mes besoins on a
besoin d'être autosuffisant au niveau
mondial
notre sujet il est celui-là pardon de le
dire quand vous allez au niveau européen
j'étais en Algérie avec la première
ministre j'ai rencontré mes collègues de
le cede tous disent comment on va faire
pour nourrir nos populations et d'où
personne se pose la question de cette
question là en disant on couvre nos
besoins et après on se fiche de ce qui
se passe dans la frontière voisine de
Méditerranée ce qui se passe en Amérique
du Sud parce qu'ils auraient un accident
climatique ça marche pas
il y a plus que jamais besoin d'échanges
la question après c'est qu'on est des
règles qui soient des règles loyales
ah non mais je préférais commencer par
un plaidoyer non pas trop de mots que
l'agriculture est plutôt réputée pour
défendre les intérêts agricoles et pas
être très allant à aller aux accords
agricoles aux accords de libre-échange
bon très bien enfin il faut quand même
se dire des choses si on veut être
sérieux la souveraineté ça nécessite des
échanges et en dérèglement climatiques
il en faudra sans doute plus et 3 je
n'ai pas honte de dire que nous avons
des filières d'excellence qu'il faut
qu'on puisse continuer à voir prospérer
à l'extérieur de nos frontières très
bien
attendez ah bah alors d'accord donc ce
n'est pas refermé sur nos sur nos
espèces alors laissez-moi finir monsieur
gay
non non c'est pas éculé parce qu'on est
plutôt dans un moment on dit il faut
plus d'accord de libre-échange non non
c'est pas éculé il y a un malentendu
pardon il y a un malentendu
alors je finis la question c'est la
loyauté des échanges donc c'est les
clauses de réciprocité on a on a mis
soyons honnêtes et modeste mon
prédécesseur ça me permet d'être
doublement modeste à cranter que le fait
que dans les accords internationaux on
est la capacité à mettre des clauses de
réciprocité
la culture générale de la Commission
européenne n'était pas de mettre ces
clauses là c'est plutôt une culture de
ben on fait jouer la compétition les
meilleurs et qui était une clause qui
était au fond de dire bah si la
production agricole se fait ailleurs
philosophie qui traîne un peu c'est
celle là on vendra des Airbus et on
n'aura pas besoin d'aller vendre de
ouais il y a une philosophie comme ça
qui existe bon la cloche de réciprocité
permet de d'essayer de compter cette
question là c'est largement devant nous
c'est à dire qu'il faut désormais que
dans chaque accord international qui
soit mixte qui soit sans demande du
Parlement j'y reviens après monsieur gay
on puisse on puisse incrémenter des
clauses est-ce qu'on va passer du de
l'ombre à la lumière d'un coup non parce
que dans chaque débat que nous aurons
sur les accords mais c'est pas ce que
vous m'avez demandé d'ailleurs mais dans
chaque débat il faut qu'on mette quels
sont les meilleurs clauses on peut pas à
la fois aussi avoir des gens qui nous
passent leur temps à nous dire il faut
qu'on respecte les défis climatiques à
l'extérieur des frontières européennes
sans que les ne serait-ce que les
clauses climatiques et les causes de
contraintes environnementales déjà
réglerait une partie de nos questions
donc je pense qu'il faut porter le fer
sur carboner des carbonées sur quels
sont les clauses environnementales que
vous portez et c'est comme ça qu'il faut
qu'il essaye d'avancer mais je le dis
avec modestie parce que je sens que le
chemin est assez long là-dessus deuxième
élément donc voilà pour les questions
troisième élément c'est la question de
la méthode c'est les accords
internationaux et puis après vous
interrogé sur le site pardon je vais
être précis
troisième élément c'est la question de
la méthode oui c'est des accords mixtes
ou des accords non mix dans un cas le
Parlement est sollicité les parlements
sont sollicités dans d'autres cas oui je
vois très bien l'exercice qui consiste à
dire
la Commission décide toute seule alors
après il y a quand même des règles de
consultation du conseil ou du Parlement
européen c'est pas complètement il y a
un Parlement européen
quand même et donc c'est aussi assez
niveau là que peuvent se poser ces
débats moi je pense par ailleurs que
nous avons un sujet démocratique
nous vous réjouissez pas trop vite mais
nous avons un sweet démocratique c'est
que il y a quelque chose qui est gênant
dans ces accords je le dis moi c'est
peut-être que je le pense c'est on donne
un mandat à la commission ça part en
sous-marin et tout d'un coup quel jour
avant l'accord on va dire voilà l'accord
et on a besoin de construire j'ai besoin
de construire moi j'ai demandé à mes
équipes de construire de voilà les
accords qu'on a devant nous parce que la
peur n'évite pas le danger oui les
Brésiliens et Monsieur Loula faut pas se
faire d'illusion il a envie de commercer
et donc il va avoir envie de réactiver
l'accord qui est en cours
voilà et donc qu'est-ce qu'on a comme
position
agricole qui nous paraissent importante
pour ne pas désorganiser tel ou tel
filière pour pouvoir promouvoir telle ou
telle filière et c'est ça qu'il faut
faire et deux il faut le faire dans une
forme qui ne soit pas une forme
sous-marine c'est à dire qu'on dit ce
qu'on est des débats parce que
je suis assez fasciné qu'on n'arrive pas
à avoir des débats 3e année 4e élément
enfin des débats comme on en a
d'ailleurs et qui sont normaux moi je
trouve quatrième élément le CETA alors
quand j'étais midi des relations avec le
Parlement je n'ai pas inscrit alors du
jour et de vous demanderez désormais au
futur à l'actuel ministre des Relations
avec le Parlement de
moche c'est pas moche mais c'est la
vérité c'est pas moche c'est la vérité
ce n'est pas moi qui vais déterminer
lors du jour sur le CETA
je dis au passage quand même
plaisanterie mise à part pardon madame
la Présidente d'avoir été malicieux avec
vous c'est
quand vous regardez aujourd'hui le
détail il est plutôt bénéficiaire pour
la France
non non non non
je ne dis pas le contraire je vous dis
pardon la balance comme la balance
commerciale n'est pas défavorable
on va laisser le ministre finir parce
que deuxième sujet la prédation
vous avez été deux il y en a peut-être
plusieurs je vais vous dire les choses
telles que je dépense sur la sur la
prédation de alors je crois me souvenir
de ce que j'ai dit à la commission de
l'Assemblée nationale j'essaie de pas
travailler mes propres propos mais
moi je pense qu'on a plusieurs sujets on
a un sujet de débat européen on l'a
porté avec mes collègues qui de dire le
statut est-ce qu'on peut parler le
statut de l'espèce qu'est-ce que ça
n'est pas de nature à réinterroger Berne
habitat plus important encore pour ceux
qui connaissent le sujet et vous je sais
que vous le connaissez
une convention interprétative de la
Directive Habitat guide interprétatif de
la Directive Habitat et je commencerai
peut-être faire ça parce que le guide
interprétatif c'est un dialogue nous à
la commission il y a pas besoin de nous
pays européen il y a pas besoin
d'uneanimité ou autre
mais ça n'a pas résumé la situation
parce que il suffit pas d'avoir raison
ou d'avoir une pensée il faut partager
dans les débats européens faut trouver
de la conviction pour emmener le maximum
de gens et avoir une majorité on sait
exprimé sur les 27 qui sont exprimés
je crois que c'est le collègue
luxembourgeois qui a dit moi je suis
défavorable mais je lui ai expliqué que
sans doute il vous croisez moins de loup
que nous mais ils arrivent peut-être
deuxième sujet il faut absolument pas
vous avez tout à fait raison et c'est
pour ça que je vous dis les pistes que
j'entrevois moi et qui doivent faire
l'objet d'un débat
national discussion nationale et par
ailleurs c'est un dialogue c'est pas
c'est le MTE qui est qui qui est le
ministère de la transition écologique
qui charge de ces questions mais vous
reconnaîtrez je me suis un peu j'ai fait
le choix de mettre ça au débat parce que
je pense que c'est important pour
avancer
il me semble qu'on a une importante
c'est il y a on a on a plusieurs choses
un il faut qu'on se mette d'accord sur
le comptage
la méthode c'est à dire qu'il faut qu'on
rétablisse de la confiance je fais
griller à faire personne simplement faut
qu'on se mette d'accord sur le comptage
parce que du comptage procède les 19%
. donc le prélèvement autorisé
premièrement c'est une question de
confiance pour pas dire aux gens si il y
en a pas s'il y en a au passage jeudi
pour être honnête intellectuellement que
personne n'a dit qu'un 500 on avait
fermé le banc non non il était inscrit
non j'essaie d'être il était inscrit que
l'objectif était d'atteindre 500 sans
dire que ça non mais non c'est pas pour
jouer sur les mots non mais c'est non
mais je non attendez je comprends que
c'était compris comme ça mais ça n'est
pas factuellement ce qui a été dit il
n'empêche que on a un sujet c'est donc
le dénombrement deuxième sujet on a
besoin de simplifier les processus de
prélèvement quand tu as besoin de
réaliser un prélèvement dommage j'ai
commencé j'avais une intuition sur le
sujet depuis très longtemps et pourtant
je suis au Loir-et-Cher j'ai pas encore
opportun un jour
c'est qu'on a un sujet le procès c'est
beaucoup trop compliqué si on ne veut
pas effectuer le quota il suffit de s'y
prendre comme c'est aujourd'hui
et ça c'est des Espérants on a un côté à
174 on est 15 novembre on est à 146
bon et personne nous remet en cause ça
donc on a besoin c'est les modalités de
tir
c'est les équipements
ça me permet de répondre
oui alors attention à ça parce qu'il y a
des départements qui vont vous dire moi
je suis un front de colonisation il faut
m'empêcher le front de colonisation et
vous dans votre département vous a dire
vous êtes sympa mais nous ça fait 25 ans
donc je
j'avance avec prudence sur ce sujet même
si en première intuition pourrait être
tout à fait net je pensais comme vous
mais en fait quand vous réfléchissez
bien
c'est plus compliqué que ça parce que à
côté contraint c'est normal vous
m'entendez pas d'ailleurs dans mon
propos dire ça fait partie de la
biodiversité simplement vous avez raison
je l'ai dit d'ailleurs publiquement
l'autre jour lors d'un déplacement dans
le dos je pense que ce qui me menace
c'est dans certains cas c'est l'élevage
et c'est le pastoralisme il va falloir
se le dire tranquillement là aussi
non mais l'élevage non mais d'abord le
pastoralisme désormais l'élevage avec
quand même des choses assez
impressionnantes c'est-à-dire qu'au
moment où certains expliquent partout
qu'il faut faire de l'extensive du
pastoralisme ils expliquent pas la
meilleure solution c'est quand même de
rentrer les animaux à l'intérieur ça ils
seront protégés du loup théorique en
plus enfin vous réconcage qu'on veut
pour faire de la désespérance Agricole
vous faites exactement comme ça donc
équipement
modalités de simplification des
prélèvements et on y a travaillé on est
en train d'y travailler avec le mpe pour
faire en sorte que nous ayons des
propositions à faire pour la saison qui
va s'ouvrir pas pour le plan loot 2024
je pense que cette année important des
éléments administratifs je vais très
vite mais
simplification des indemnisations
simplification des délais
de part de financement de la prévention
ça c'est chez nous ministère de
l'Agriculture parce que on peut pas
avoir 12 à 18 mois pour être enfin dit
c'est plus court sur l'indemnisation et
je le dis c'est le MTE mais c'est plus
long chez nous pour des raisons qui sont
comme c'est des fonds européens c'est un
peu plus compliqué mais il va falloir
qu'on essaie de trouver des solutions
pour pas que vous embauchiez le berger
en janvier et vous soyez payé en
décembre parce que la trésorerie c'est
le c'est l'éleveur qu'il a fait donc ça
c'est un problème on va dire les choses
comme elles sont donc on a besoin de
travailler aussi on a besoin de tenir
compte dans l'indemnisation c'est pas la
brebis qu'on a retrouvé égorgée
seulement c'est celle qui ont disparu et
c'est celle qu'on va avorter
et c'est la pierre génétique
si on reconnaît pas la pergénétique
c'est le travail de l'agriculteur et de
l'éleveur
oui et il faut il faut
j'essaie de pas être trop trop maniché
parfois ça peut être la protection
parfois ça l'est pas et il faut assumer
aussi je me suis fait alors je me fais
plein d'amis avec ce que je suis en
train de dire mais j'assume ma position
parce que la désespérance et ça ce que
je veux dire d'un éleveur il se trouve
que dans le douche je suis arrivé le
matin d'une attaque faut voir l'état de
désespérance de quelqu'un on dit ah bah
c'est comme ça merci de ta contribution
à la biodiversité et par ailleurs
l'activité d'élevage elle contribue à la
biodiversité donc pour une biodiversité
on prend le risque de faire disparaître
tout un pan de biodiversité le maintien
des prairies le réseau le réseau de tout
ça contribuant au tourisme dans des
départements comme les vôtres comme le
tout la département qui sont dans cette
situation là et donc on peut pas tout
sacrifier c'est c'est c'est lunaire
qu'on n'arrive pas à dire des choses
aussi simplement que je le dis avec
pondération comme je le dis enfin il
faut quand même qu'on saisisse de cette
question et donc
ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il faut pas
qu'on se retranche seulement dans
l'affaire européenne et Berne parce que
ça nous empêcherait d'avancer quatrième
élément il faut qu'on documente ce que
je suis en train de dire est-ce que vous
dites je sens est-ce que je perçois de
comment on peut faire cohabiter
pastoralisme il y a des moments faut
assumer que ça ne peut pas cohabiter
que c'est compliqué à faire cohabiter ne
serait-ce que ça les agriculteurs
auraient besoin de l'entendre
ne serait-ce que ça par tous ceux qui
donnent des leçons à longueur de média
ne serait-ce que ça voilà donc voilà ce
que je voulais dire sur la prédation
comme vous avez compris c'est un sujet
oui alors l'abri alors pardon dans les
mécanismes alors la brigade loup alors
elle est elle est plutôt prépositionnée
c'est plutôt libre c'est les moyens MTE
ça dans les Pyrénées
parce que c'est Massif Central parce que
c'est plutôt dans le Massif Central
voilà bien sûr alors après je dis on
peut pas demander il y a un réseau qui
marche très bien pardon et qu'il faut
valoriser c'est les louvetiers il faut
les former
faut les accompagner il faut les dire
équipement qui leur permettent juste de
voir dans des conditions acceptables
je viens je l'ai dit
ouais j'ai des idées j'ai quelques îles
donc voilà tout ça ça me permet de dire
c'est tous ces enregistre là qu'il faut
faire et dans le plan Louis il faut dire
ça c'est possible ça c'est pas possible
ça c'est protégeable ça c'est pas
protégeable voilà j'en arrive à la
question de l'eau vous m'avez interrogé
à plusieurs reprises sur la question de
l'eau
là aussi j'aimerais qu'on arrive à poser
un débat assez tranquillement
il y a besoin mais j'essaie de répondre
à des sujets un peu la question de l'eau
on y reviendra sur moi plusieurs
reprises je partage un il y a besoin
d'eau on agriculture il va falloir qu'on
l'entende partout il va falloir qu'on
l'entende le dérèglement climatique il
va produire des dérèglements et des
arythmies pluviométriques
donc il va falloir qu'on assume que dans
les périodes où il y a trop d'eau on en
récupère et que dans les périodes où il
y a pas assez d'eau en plus 3 ça
n'empêche pas qu'on puisse le faire et
c'est ça qui est désespérant dans le
projet qui est en controversé et dont on
parle c'est que ça n'empêche pas que
dans ces territoires là on a un certain
nombre de de mesures qui sont prises
pour réduire les produits
phytosanitaires pour réduire les
prélèvements c'est un projet celui qui
est controversé où on réduit dans la
période estivale des deux tiers le
prélèvement et on réduit deux un tiers
le prélèvement la période d'été et on
réduit globalement d'un tiers le
prélèvement net donc on passe de 20
millions de mètres cubes à 12 ou 13
millions de mètres cubes il y a quand
même moins d'eau qui est prélevé donc
c'est quand même un système vertueux ça
me permet de répondre à votre question
monsieur le sénateur au passage moi je
pense qu'on a besoin de construire du
collectif après faut que tout le monde
parce que dans le projet en question il
y a des associations
qui ont signé le protocole
et qu'on retrouve aujourd'hui à à
promouvoir au niveau national
l'inverse de ce qu'ils ont signé donc à
un moment faut être de bonne foi dans
cette affaire pas vous c'est pas le
sujet là c'est dès lors qu'on fait un
projet territorial on signe on signe pas
quand on signe on signe et quand c'est
purgé des questions juridiques on y va
et donc moi je fais toutes les semaines
une revue de projet pour regarder les
projets qui existent ce qu'on peut
déployer et on a besoin de travailler
sur du collectif moi je pense qu'on a
une question c'est utilisation des
ouvrages à quoi ça sert
parce que ça peut être irrigation lutte
de la maintient des étiages lutte contre
le les inondations lutte contre la les
incendies
alimentation en eau potable et
d'ailleurs à la vérité et quand vous
regardez je sais plus qui l'a dit c'est
plutôt c'est les PTG oui mais oui mais
dans plein de cas c'est déjà des PTG les
projets dont on parle
mais si non mais il y a une il y a
quelque chose qui est mortifère dans le
débat qu'on a sur ces questions là la
prédation c'est la même chose c'est
retour à l'état de nature
et ça c'est là c'est la mort de
l'agriculture ça ou alors on revient 10
000 ans en arrière donc je pense ça ne
veut pas dire qu'il faut pas faire des
efforts sur le prélèvement des efforts
de pratique il y a des territoires où on
va faire je sais plus qui me l'a dit il
y a des cultures qu'on ne fera plus dans
certains territoires ce que le
dérèglement climatique va le rendre
impossible il faut aussi l'assumer et je
l'assumerai j'ai pas de difficulté avec
ça et donc c'est un élément important
mais donc faut qu'on arrive à poser le
débat ça nécessite on accompagne les
agriculteurs qu'on finance les ouvrages
on a mis 45 millions dans le pense
prendre le lance il faut qu'on déploie
mais avec une vigilance pour dire
attention c'est pas un droit comme ça
c'est chacun fait sa part de
responsabilité et quand c'est une
gouvernance collective c'est mieux parce
qu'on peut pas faire grief de tel ou
telle accaparement qui n'en est pas un
enfin au moins ça permet de détendre les
choses ça me permet de dire
alors question alimentaire premier
dispositif chaque alimentaire
reconnaissons que c'est un dispositif on
lui demande tout chez qualimentaire on
lui demande de questionner les
redémarrage c'était pour ça plutôt de
après la question de la précarité d'un
certain nombre de gens de permettre à
des gens d'accéder à une alimentation de
qualité on lui demande de pouvoir
organiser les filières on lui demande de
assumer la transition viande vers
végétale on lui demande de faire de la
qualité on lui demande moi je vais vous
dire la conviction g c'est impossible de
tout faire avec un chèque alimentaire
d'où je ne sais plus qu'il a dit l'idée
pour moi que
qu'on commence et ce qu'on fait c'est
peut-être vous c'est ce qu'on commence à
se qu'on fait avec Jean-Christophe con
on a dédié un premier fond
supplémentaire de 60 millions d'euros
via
les banques les associations en
particulier les banques alimentaires
parce que c'est première étage n'est pas
au bout de la réflexion mais il semble
que c'est un élément
il me semble que c'est un élément très
important d'essayer de travailler sur ce
sujet là première étape c'est celle là
il y a les Banques Alimentaires je pense
que dans la restauration collective ça
revient alors c'est pas ce que comme ça
que vous l'avez pris tout à l'heure mais
dans la restauration collective je te
dirai après tout est-ce que c'est pas la
meilleure voie et moyen pour faire
découvrir à des jeunes générations qui
parfois sont assez éloignées des
questions de qualité alimentaire de leur
apporter dans ce modèle là de la
diversité plutôt que de faire un chèque
qui va se terminer au supermarché moi je
pense que c'est une bonne question de le
poser comme ça enfin j'ai presque fini
donc voilà c'est les quatre points que
je voulais évoquer
vous avez évoqué les contentieux
aéronautiques c'est bien noté de toute
façon évidemment vous en doutez que
c'est une chose qui sur lequel on va
avancer la loi s'en passe tous alors
pardon
les propositions de décret sont au
Conseil d'État depuis 30 août
le Conseil d'État a délibéré c'est
peut-être pour ça que c'est dans la
presse aujourd'hui je crois ce jour
voilà donc
on y est presque
voilà c'est hier dans contexte de comme
on lit contexte
quelque chose dans le métier que
j'exerçais je sais que quand j'étais
assez bien renseigné et donc ça passe
tous ça avance parce que et donc on l'a
fait le 30 août on n'a pas je dis pas
qu'on était très en avance mais on a
fait le travail côté et c'est normal que
le Conseil d'État il a c'est parfait
très sollicité puisse le faire
dégustation gratuite c'est pas un sujet
législatif législatif pardon c'est un
sujet douanes
je toc le sel je joue ça je répondrai
sur le sel parce que ça j'ai pas
l'arêtement de réponse les alternatives
alors ce cardan est plus là mais je
voulais juste dire une chose moi je
je trouve pardon je trouve que c'est
dommage de dire il y a pas de modèle
alternatif il faut qu'on trouve un
modèle qui soit durable et le modèle
durable la bio est est un des modèles
qui porte en soi c'est pas le seul
mais la question de dire parce que c'est
pardon vous dites monsieur Cardon a dit
il faut remettre un peu de d'urbanité
dans le monde rural et si on mettait un
peu de ruralité et d'urbanité dans le
monde urbain ça serait pas mal aussi
hein pardon vis-à-vis du monde agricole
c'est pas ce que vous avez dit mais il
faut que tout le monde se comprenne dans
cette affaire là parce que c'est les
injonctions à des gens à qui on n'est
pas capable de dire comment je te paye
cette injonction là c'est que c'est
compliqué et deux je trouve qu'on ferait
défaut mais c'est mon avis personnel en
disant j'impose je pense qu'il faut
laisser tout le monde faire son chemin
et tout le monde est pas au même degré
de conscience qu'il y a des modèles qui
sont plus compliqués que d'autres à
faire transiter et que de dire il y a un
bon modèle il va il y a les bons et les
méchants donc c'est pas comme ça que
vous l'avez dit mais on est on est en
train d'essayer de faire moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est pas ceux qui sont le
plus en avant et les plus en point de
techniquement sur les questions c'est
ceux qui sont le plus loin
c'est cela qu'il faut embarquer parce
que c'est cela qui sont les plus en
risque ça me permet au passage de
répondre à la question de Pierre Cuypers
au risque je ne veux pas lui être
désagréable mais on peut pas à la fois
dire il faut qu'on en sorte et à chaque
fois qu'on dit il va on va en sortir ou
être prévenu que je parle pas des
néonicotines mais
non alors d'abord l'endive il y a rien
comme décision de 4 la décision il y a
une rencontre le 12 décembre de c'est
une décision européenne donc c'est quand
même pas une sur transmission française
3 il va falloir qu'on assume le fait que
les CMR 1 en particulier il y a un
certain nombre de molécules on va en
sortir donc la question n'est pas de
savoir si on va échapper à la sortie la
question c'est qu'il faut qu'on mette
des moyens sur la recherche pour pour
non mais c'est oui non mais le temps est
court mais parfois à force de pas avoir
vu c'est encore un peu
bah non il y a des produits pardon il
faut qu'on en sorte et moi j'assume ça
aussi même si c'est pour ça que j'ai pas
envie d'être désagréable néonicotinoïd
on sait on sait tout le monde s'est
engagé sur des moyens tout le monde
s'est engagé sur une durée moi j'ai du
mal à penser qu'on deviendrait
facilement devant le Parlement en disant
bon bah il faut 3 ans
donc attendons alors 2023 moi je pense
qu'il faut poursuivre le processus on va
attendre les résultats l'inrae les
résultats des travaux on va regarder les
solutions alternatives on va regarder
l'accompagnement mais nous commençons
pas par c'est parce que vous avez dit
attendez nous commençons pas par dire
2024 quand on a même pas commencé 2023
oui mais il faut penser à 2024 sans les
néo nicotinoïdes d'abord bah si
oui
pardon je suis un peu symétrique là mais
j'essaye de dire il faut pas
l'interdiction sans solution mais il
faut qu'on cherche les solutions
bon quand même Pascal à la fin il y en
aura plus
il faut non
monsieur Duplan vous êtes en forme vous
êtes taquin non mais je le dis parce que
c'est un sujet important il faut qu'on
assume le fait c'est pas simplement je
c'est mon sujet n'est pas de dire de
faire plaisir à tel ou tel le sujet
c'est que c'est des molécules on sait
qu'elle porte leur lot de contraintes
mais fais pas par plaisir et au niveau
européen aussi bon comme ils sont
européenne donc monsieur le ministre me
permet de vous interrompre parce que il
vous reste énormément de questions à
répondre et je ne voudrais pas me fâcher
avec le président Larcher et encore
moins avec le récipient d'air de la
décoration que vous allez remettre que
je ne connais pas mais je veux pas me
fâcher avec lui ou elle d'ailleurs je
sais pas je vous propose peut-être juste
d'évoquer l'histoire de l'énergie voilà
sur les stockages sur la transformation
et ensuite le reste des réponses je vous
propose de nous répondre par écrit et je
vous demande la faveur de revenir au
mois de janvier
qui n'auront pas été traités jusqu'à
présent si vous acceptez voilà voilà
donc peut-être juste un peu sur la
question énergétique en fait on a
plusieurs il y a trois dispositifs
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est le dernier
c'est ce qu'on appelait le guichet tout
à l'heure dans l'intervention donc là
c'est là par rapport aux endives en
particulier parce que les endives ce que
vous parlez c'est les deux autres
guichets dans lesquels il rentre pas
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai besoin que
vous me documentiez sur ces sujets là
parce que il y a pas comme les filières
sont pas homogènes dans leurs besoins
leur appel d'énergie la façon dont elle
fonctionne les individus ils en ont
besoin sur trois mois donc ils
rentraient pas du tout dans le précédent
dispositif donc nous on est en train de
travailler avec les filières pour
essayer vraiment de bonne foi de trouver
un dispositif qui colle donc faites nous
remonter je suis en contact avec j'ai à
peu près le même exemple parce que je
crois que c'est la même personne sur la
question non mais sur l'exemple mais
c'est pas un reproche c'est censé 150
300 800
on l'a passé à Bercy donc on a mais il
faut qu'on se documente ça pour dire où
sont les trous est-ce que c'est un cas
particulier ou est-ce que c'est toute
une filière qui est en train de prendre
son risque donc on est en train de
travailler pour ajuster le dispositif et
pour faire en sorte que l'on soit plus
le plus près de la réalité on aura des
trous dans la raquette on va ça me sur
la Drôme j'en ai parlé l'autre jour je
vous ai même cité d'ailleurs aussi je me
souviens bien les parlementaires nous
ont nous ont sollicité là la question là
il y a le dispositif simplement le
statut hybride a dit votre collègue de
l'Assemblée nationale madame Antoine a
dit statut hybride oui le statut hybride
fait que ça rentre pas dans la case mais
globalement ça rentrerait dans le
dispositif ce qui est pas le cas d'un
certain nombre aujourd'hui de filières
donc on y travaille je reconnais avec
modestie c'est tellement complexe cette
affaire là mais c'est plutôt le guichet
pour nous pour ces filières là il me
semble que c'est plutôt dans le cadre du
guichet qui rentrerait au-delà des 13
énergos intensifs mais là c'est plutôt
les grandes industries agroalimentaires
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire madame
la Présidente vous remercions bon merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre je sais
qu'il y a des frustrations dans les
réponses mais au moins les questions ont
été posées enregistrées et je pense que
vos services pour nous répondre par
écrit et je vous donne rendez-vous dans
l'hémicycle pour le PLF qu'on a
finalement assez peu à bordé